[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
donc cette ce RCS je suis pas sûr en
fait ce que c'est exactement mais
c'est pas impressionnant ce début de ce
début de show mais j'ai un léger souci
technique ça m'agace j'arrive pas à
avoir les joueurs mais ils ont commencé
je pense que c'est la RCS Cup et vous
verrez de la pub pour nos amis de rings
voilà pour l'instant j'arrive pas à
avoir les joueurs mais on a la partie et
c'est ça qui est bien
et on a la partie entre Maxime va chier
La Grave et
à les raisins
fille rouge à on les a pas à l'écran
mais c'est pas très grave c'est quoi le
format c'est du 15 + 3 les deux joueurs
français jouent ensemble on va regarder
un petit tour vers le bracket avant de
s'intéresser à cette nageddorf
le bracket qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a
8 joueurs qui sont qualifiés pour la
finale
déjà pour cette division 1 cette finale
de Division 1 avec Carlson Nakamura qui
a déjà commencé depuis un moment en
éponyashi fille rouge à Maxime Vacher la
grave pour avoir les matchs en différé
enfin ils sont pas ils sont ils sont pas
en simultanés donc ça commence à 5 10
minutes à chaque fois il décale un petit
peu les débuts de partie donc on va
pouvoir tout voir on a le duel
franco-français c'est un hasard allez
zafiruja et Maxime ma chaîne ils sont
très bons et
il se trouve qu'il joue ensemble dans
ces 8 joueurs et on a la zavie contre ma
média ROV c'est au meilleur des quatre
parties donc on verra peut-être on verra
certainement quatre parties et s'il y a
deux partout ensuite qu'est-ce qu'on a
et bien on a un armage et dont le
nécessaire Armageddon on va voir ça tout
de suite je vais vous mettre le petit
live board
parce que là
ça doit être ça
vous avez le petit liveboard où vous
pouvez regarder tout ça on va voir le
début de la partie avec
aérésa qui a les blancs qui commencent
par E4 donc on va la nage d'or favorite
de mvl et fouger 5 attention c'est la
grosse ligne celle qui est permis à
Fabienne ocaron a deux battre maxi
machines aggrave dans cette fameuse
ronde de 8 des candidats celle qui
s'était joué un an après la rendre 7 une
partie assez extraordinaire qu'on avait
suivi notamment avec Jules Moussard à
l'époque
f4d6 il va toujours pour le fameux pur
empoisonné des lignes favorites de Gary
castorv et de Bobby Fisher mais allez
ASA dit non ce n'est pas le pur
empoisonné je protège mon pion qui est
l'autre option et joue Kai BD7 Maxime
évidemment la ligne principale c'est
dames D2 dame prend B2 à 3 on a pris un
pion mais évidemment on a on est allé à
la pêche avec la dame on a perdu
beaucoup de temps donc les blancs
peuvent attaquer au centre c'est très
intéressant il y a énormément de
théories mais les Noirs normalement sont
ok
en protège ce cavalier en F6 dame 2 on
menace 5 on prépare le grand rock tout
ça et archiologique archi connu d'AMS C7
pourquoi mc7 on empêche 5 et on veut
aussi faire jouer B5 on fera pression
ici et on pourra développer le fou en B7
pas en B6 grand rock B5 A3 foot 7 3 B1
tour B8 maintenant en menace B4
attention
damer empêche B4 vous voyez tous ces
coups et permet de sortir ce fou
pourquoi ça empêche becape parce que si
on fait B4 il y a puis on prend pour
prendre et je suppose que cahier des 5
des idées comme ça avec la dame qui
ajoute un oeil sur la tour vont être
très très dangereuse on attaque la dame
en attaque la tour on gagne du matériel
donc évidemment Maxime il fait pas ça il
joue fou B7 fous des trois protège
et H6 x H4
cavalier C5 et c'est une position très
très intéressante typique de hannage
d'orf entre les deux joueurs français
alors je vais voir ce qu'on me dit en
coulisses parce que là on va voir plein
de messages là on m'envoie plein de
messages est-ce que c'est bon ou pas
pour les est-ce que je suis cote ou pas
on sait pas on sait pas j'y comprends
rien
j'y comprends rien est-ce que je suis
cost ou pas et un duel au sommet pour la
France ça serait sympa quand même
d'avoir les joueurs
je sais pas je sais pas je vais voir on
va essayer de voir le
col zoom je me déconcentre un petit peu
on va faire épingler ouais mais après
comment je fais pour épingler l'autre
c'est ça que je comprends pas
je vais faire
passer quand tu partages épingler et
est-ce que je peux épingler aussi notre
cher ami
ajoutez l'épingle
ah bah là ça va être bien
là ça va être bien je réponds yes et je
vais vous faire ça en direct take fresh
take fresh va vous faire ça en direct et
oui on va aller chercher les joueurs on
voit les deux joueurs qui sont là mais
là vous allez voir Maxime avec les Noirs
regardez j'avais fait une superbe
préparation mais ça marchait pas du tout
mais là ça marche toujours pas mais
c'est pas grave parce que là
hop là et on va faire ça en direct sous
vos yeux ébahis
[Musique]
je me ridiculiser en direct télé la
question normalement devrait les voir ah
voilà on va aller voir voilà hop là je
vous fais part de mes prouesses
techniques en direct qui c'est qu'on va
voir arriver c'est notre ami Ali resa
évidemment notre ami ouh là là n'importe
quoi
c'est pas grave hop là allez raisin on
va lui prendre
toute on va lui prendre toute sa caméra
on va le mettre comme ça voilà c'est
tardif mais bon
c'est mieux que rien écoutez hop là je
mets alien comme ça et Maxime Maxime il
va être un Maxime
et Maxime il va être de l'autre côté on
va le chercher aussi take fraise pour
vous servir en direct parce qu'on
m'avait pas filé les c'était pas de ma
faute je préfère tout de suite prévenir
les médisants du chat c'était pas du
tout de ma faute
je fais un peu en direct mais bon ok
je fais un peu en direct je suis désolé
normalement il faut le faire horsel mais
bon c'est pas grave vous voyez les la
technique quoi la technique en direct
évidemment demain je le ferai je le
ferai avant j'en avais pas donné les
droits et on voit maximum en plein écran
c'est sympa aussi
regardez-moi ça hop là il est à Maxime
oh il a le maillot d'équipe de France
d'accord ça crée Maxime et regardez on
va le mettre en petit pour voir l'écran
voilà voilà on a ça c'est mieux que rien
on a fait les deux joueurs
et j'essaierai de faire salut
ouais non je montre évidemment vous
rigolez ah non je peux pas montrer la
partie de de Magnus là faut pas exagérer
on a on a on a un duel franco-français
on a envie de le voir on a tous envie de
le voir et aussi il y a une question de
suprématie alors évidemment la
suprématie en long terme
ouais belle leçon technique ouais tu te
fous de moi Nathan qu'est-ce qui me
disait là sur ça je vais te balancer moi
je vais balancer le message privé
ouais je me rappelle plus comment on
fait pour le truc faire le truc horsen
alors
comment on fait le chrono ça bug ah ben
ouais tu as raison le chrono ça bug
et tu as complètement raison et là
est-ce qu'il bug le chrono
il bug plus c'est le mode studio et il
est où le mode studio
mode studio je vois pas à chaque fois je
le rate et à chaque fois on me dit où il
est et à chaque fois je me dis mais oui
mais c'est bien sûr
c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable on va parler d'échec
quand même
ça c'est le live et donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'il a pris c'est
logique de prendre puis on prend ses 5
E5 kd5
[Musique]
qui prend des cinq fous prends des 5
fous prendre le 16 ben écoutez ça a
l'air quand même très correct pour les
noirs on a réussi à sortir tout des
pièces on va ok gentiment on a quand
même
des arguments par là il a joué feux 4
allezza faut prendre le cadre 1.4 et
petit retour des 6 et il joue sur cette
colonne finalement c'est le seul
avantage
et il partage des images oh là là c'est
fabuleux le mode studio il se moque de
moi là ou quoi
il se moque de moi Nathan faut faire
mieux Nathan là
le mode studio je vois pas où c'est bon
mais ouais comme ça je pourrais vous
faire
je pourrais vous faire ça pas en direct
en bas en droite dans commande
un transition de scène
en commande mode studio ben oui je suis
mais voilà je me suis exactement dit je
me suis exactement dit comme la dernière
fois et comme à chaque fois que je
demande c'est vraiment je suis vraiment
crétin de demander ça après autant
d'années et oui il y a le mode studio
effectivement donc je vous ferai ça à la
prochaine fois
en différé bon c'est pas grave on a les
deux joueurs on est là c'est une partie
on a pas raté grand chose dans le début
alors ça commençait bien que c'est le
nage de fou G5 mais il faut dire qu'elle
est Raisa a pas essayé d'attraper Maxime
complètement dans cette dans cette ligne
et il a joué un peu mou alors B4 on
essaie évidemment d'ouvrir les les
colonnes pour les tours parce qu'on sait
que la colonne D elle est pour les
blancs
il joue à 4 et sur B3 il joue C3 très
logique à l'IRISA il essaie de fermer le
jeu à fond je fais un petit coup de
refresh comme ça on l'aura en couleur
marron foncé et donc ces trois
évidemment on rappelle qu'on aura il y a
un incrément c'est du 15 + 3 c'est
marqué au dessus c'est voilà je fais une
petite présentation quart de finale
cadence 15 plus 3 je me suis quand même
fatigué je vous rappelle à tout
programmer hier dimanche on travaille le
dimanche ici à chascom c'est dur à
droite vous avez à droite vous avez le
gain du match et la face CAO donc gain
du match à 2,5 ko c'est maintenant c'est
ce qui joue qui ont réussi à se
qualifier certains ont tenté de se
qualifier on Tera les noms mais ils ont
pas réussi
et vous avez donc en bas en bas donc mon
twitter déjà mon x ex vous pouvez me
suivre et ainsi que évidemment les
réseaux sociaux de chaisescom pour ne
rien rater et le direct donc si vous
voulez réfléchir à votre cadence et bien
vous avez toujours la position indirecte
qui est ici où il y a marqué direct
c'est pas très compliqué et là je fais
des flèches pour vous expliquer que Ali
resa à la colonne D et donc c'est un
avantage au moins en pratique après le
roi est quand même dans les courants
d'air plus ou moins il y a un pion qui
est très embêtant ici
mais ça manque de colonne ouvertes à la
limite ouais donc ils jouent autour des
8 d'abord ok tour HD1 va suivre parce
que c'est vraiment le seul argument des
blancs dans cette position c'est de de
contrôler cette cette colonne D
le pur à 4 et un peu isolé certes mais
il est protégé il est bien protégé par
la dame c'est quoi le on va regarder
peut-être le format le format c'est très
simple il y a des qualifications ouverts
tous les titrés comme on vous l'avez dit
bah voilà il y a des grands maîtres qui
ont qui ont réussi notre qui ont raté
événement pour les jeunes c'est la
dernière
icup qui aura la grande finale à Toronto
au mois de décembre je bluffe un peu
mais je crois que c'est ça playoff tout
rondes des 8 joueurs les deux premiers
vont en phase finale tout ça c'est pour
les califes
finales 4 joueurs demi-finale au
meilleur des trois sets de 4 parties ah
ouais ça c'est pour la grande finale et
on voit le trophée du tournoi regardez
ça ça va être beau ça va être en direct
et voilà on voit cette Haye Cup je sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire c'est
vraiment honteux c'est un things Cup je
pense
je suis même pas sûr ou artificial
intelligence non mais je pense pas je
pense que c'est vraiment c'est un signe
je sais même pas en fait ce que ça veut
dire
la tente tu sais toi
tu sais ou pas
artificiel intelligence merci Nathan
je crois ou alors c'est ring je sais que
nos amis de harcing sont revenus dans la
et opéra aussi ils sont revenus opéra
c'est notre sponsor oh là là j'ai pas
hâte
intelligence artificielle je vous mets
le doute à make-up ça se ah ben oui sur
disant tu tombes bien tu tombes bien tu
tombes bien mon cher
mon cher ce XO slow Opera le meilleur
celui que j'ai toujours utilisé regardez
vous avez en bas le navigateur vraiment
il est extraordinaire sans pub sans pub
opéra extraordinaire moi je suis avec
pub merci pour voir si l'air est bon le
CO2 les minces
je me rappelle plus c'est ça ça mesure
ça mesure tout plein de choses que je
vais vous montrer d'ailleurs regardez ça
si j'ai pas bien bossé là hop là et
voilà les ppm 633 c'est pas bon pour
Magnus faut 500 le taux d'humidité la
température
air quality God ils sont pas dur ils
sont ils sont pas
bon
c'est en bas de moi donc Magnus Carson
tout va bien voilà tout va bien mais
attention mauvaise pente 633 c'est pas
bon
c'est pas bon du tout voilà donc je
remets la position en direct avec Maxime
achève qui réfléchit 9 minutes pour 8
minutes pour aller Raisa tous les
joueurs jouent ensemble il y a Carlson
Nakamura évidemment aujourd'hui mais je
crois qu'on fait le choix de rester de
rester sur nos amis
parce que franchement
[Musique]
si tu s'y redonnes les caméras les
joueurs plus bas ça devrait se caler
dans le trou de Verlaine
ah ouais d'accord oui oui tu as raison
tu as raison c'est assez bien vu ça
c'est assez bien vu je vais faire ça ah
oui il a raison
c'est bien artificial intelligence voilà
tout à fait bon c'est pas tout à fait
ouais pas tout à fait dans le trou
effectivement
je le ferai la pause à la poche j'en ai
des trucs à faire moi je vous le dire
c'est chaud c'était chaud ce début de
ils m'ont pas donné les droits de s'ils
sont habitués à me voir jouer aussi en
même temps c'est normal
alors on va voir mais en tout cas on a
quatre parties de très haut niveau et
c'est aussi comme j'expliquais tout à
l'heure c'est aussi une sorte de lutte
pour un suprématie française alors
évidemment allez va très en moins un
rendez-vous compte 2003 à 90 pour mvl il
a plus d'élo le temps joue à sa faveur
ça c'est une évidence mais merci mais il
a montré que dans ce speech par exemple
il était là
donc effectivement
ça
tout reste tout reste
tout reste a prouvé là à les raisins
penser match gain du match à deux points
et demi tout à fait tout à fait c'est
marqué c'est marqué cette face ko c'est
vrai que j'ai pas bien centré je le
referai je joue pas moi je joue pas je
ne suis pas qualifié pour ce tournoi
malheureusement entourage D1 il
réfléchit Maxime qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire
est-ce qu'il peut prendre j'ai
l'impression pas vraiment j'ai
l'impression qu'on va reprendre du pion
là du coup ça crée un pion passé très
fort les blancs peuvent rendre menaces
vous me direz donc il y a pas d'urgence
non plus c'est un peu bizarre comme
position et Maxime qui prend son temps
moi j'aime quand Maxime prend son temps
peut-être un de ces quatre il menace
ouais tout simplement pour chatouiller
les pions de dame qui peut qui sont des
forces évidemment parce que le roi est
quand même embêté mais qui peuvent être
aussi des faiblesses et tu reprends des
6 jouer alors maintenant c'est un grand
choix c'est un grand choix pour aller
résa et il prend du pion vous voyez
c'est la c'est la différence entre lui
et moi c'est que c'est un choix qui
m'aurait pris du temps ce truc parce que
je me suis j'aurais hésité voilà on
garde la colonne on la garde pas on crée
un pion passé
au feeling on crée le pion passé quand
même parce qu'il est très proche de la
de la casse dans but comme on dit là la
Coupe du monde de rugby donc on va
parler en termes
de rugby mais
d'un autre côté on a pu à colonne
ouverte pour la tour donc c'est
c'était fallait faire une petite
concession
alors
comment on fait maintenant peut-être
d'un de ces quatre qui fait une sorte de
bingo sur A6 sur C5 intéressant même ces
quatre alors comment on ferait sur MC4
avec des Noirs peut-être tourbé 6 dans
ton V6
alors c'est ce que je calculé à voix
haute ouais 4 marche pas c'est pas mal
c'est quelques échecs certes ouh là de
me prendre ici c'était pas le bon coup
visiblement qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire il y a un perpète ou quoi D7 on
pousse c'est ça et on fait dame ok oui
c'est vrai que c'est mieux effectivement
si on peut faire ça non c'était juste
pour montrer que c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal en général c'est dangereux mais
c'est pas mal
mesdames et cette qu'est-ce qu'il fait
il fait G4 il lance l'attaque la saut de
l'autre côté c'est vrai qu'il a envie
aussi d'affaiblir ce
roi donc ça a beaucoup de sens de faire
G4
qui est intéressant
intéressant ce G4
pour faire F5 ensuite et affaiblir le
roi à long terme pas évident de voir ce
qu'on fait avec les noirs
et 7 minutes pour
contre simplement six minutes donc
quatre parties je rappelle aujourd'hui
entre ces deux joueurs peut-être 5 avec
le fameux Armageddon et le fameux
Armageddon je le rappelle on le rappelle
le format de l'Armageddon il est très
simple 15 minutes pour les blancs et
ensuite c'est une sorte de vente aux
enchères des noirs on met par exemple
moi si je mets 12 minutes
Nathan mais 11 minutes bah du coup
Nathan allez noir et 11 minutes il gagne
l'enchère mais il a que 11 minutes
contre mes 15 et en plus
non il y a rien en plus il a le droit de
faire nulle par contre donc si il fait
nul il gagne la partie
il y a un perpète sans la tour ce jeu
m'étonnera toujours voyons on va on va
le regarder donc j'ai 4 au lieu de MC4
la variante c'était de MC4 pourquoi il y
a un perpète d'ailleurs
pourquoi c'est où le perpète j'ai pas
compris ah oui à perpète oui d'accord il
y a perpète dame 4 si on va en serrer
Adam c'est deux et si on va un il y a
dans ma 4 ok donc et la différence avec
ça pourquoi ah jolie jolie jolie jolie
parce qu'elle Adam qui revient et donc
il y a plus de perpète voilà
voilà pour la petite histoire
de se perpète vous n'avez pas compris
the tomber 6
on attaque le pion en D6 c'est tout à
fait logique de la part de Maxime
invitant une répétition mais il est ok
évidemment il est noir il est quand même
un peu moins bien il faut quand même
s'organiser pour défendre le pion des 6
comment fait-on
comment fait-on et bien dame 5 serait
tentant mesdames 5 il y a le pion quand
même et encore une fois
encore une fois il y a le pion qui
pousse donc dans le 5 et un coup
dame 5 et même est tellement un coup
qu'il a été joué par les raisins
il était joué par aliasa donc je
rappelle vous avez la jauge évidemment
la barre que vous connaissez que vous
avez en bas pour le live et aussi pour
l'analyse pour vous montrer donc mes
analyses voilà donc vous avez la jauge
mais je n'utilise pas l'ordinateur donc
effectivement parfois
je propose des lignes moins bien que
l'ordinateur soyez rassuré
même souvent régulièrement
donc comment on fait pour protéger
maintenant il me reste très direct la
menace très direct c'est espion
et il faut le protéger j'aime pas la
jauge ça me spoile ouais je suis désolé
moi je suis pas hyper fan mais c'est
vrai que dans les dans les layout comme
on dit cheesecom la jauge est quand même
proposé
et donc bon ben c'est vrai que c'est dur
rapide moi je suis plutôt fan en partie
longue non mais en rapide je trouve ça
sympa
justement parce que je rate des choses
les gens la réclament souvent en
ordinateur
ouais bah alors après il y a le pour
elle contre
mais effectivement
on va voir ce qu'il va faire après dame
5 c'est pas évident pour maximiser alors
le problème de tour C6 par exemple c'est
que c'est passif tout simplement on va
continuer avec F5 comme ça et c'est pas
clair quelle est notre prochain coup
donc ça c'est un coup qu'on rechigne à
jouer mais en même temps
faut trouver un coup alors est-ce qu'on
pousse
il y a pas 50 options à mon avis sur
dame 5 il y a C4 C6 celui que dame prend
à 4 pair tout de suite à cause de décès
et on fait dame
je suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr de ce qui va jouer notre
ami Maxime
il n'y a pas l'air sur non plus la me 5
tours c'est 6 jouer un peu passif mais
bon l'école française de la souffrance
après tout
qu'est-ce qui va se passer peut-être F5
maintenant je suppose voir G5 c'est une
autre option ou alors H4 enfin quelque
chose allait le droit ça c'est à peu
près garanti
c'est à peu près garanti qu'il se passe
quelque chose à l'endroit alors comment
exactement on continue cette attaque
je suis pas sûr
5,50 pour aller résa à fil rouge à
contre 3,40 simplement pour Maxime c'est
très très rare d'avoir un maximum moins
bien au temps mais ça veut dire qu'il
prend ce match avec beaucoup de sérieux
on sait bien c'est bien parce que
on va on va voir du Grand Maxime on a du
grand maximum en ce moment il a un
rappel si vous l'avez suivi avec moi le
tata style India rapide il a gagné il a
fait une troisième non il a pas fini 3e
dans nos rêves il a fini 3e mais en vrai
il a fini 5e et il a fait très très beau
parcours au
championne chest tour non au speeches
pardon où il a battu d'abord goûte
ensuite Sarine de manière très très
convaincante et éclatante et ensuite il
a perdu contre
Nakamura il menait avant la phase de
Bullet donc il a vraiment été très
impressionnant
et finalement manus Carlsen a battu
Nakamura vendredi ouais j'ai suivi j'ai
suivi le le speechess c'était assez
formidable
ce match entre j'ai pas pu voir la fin
malheureusement j'avais des obligations
mais
j'ai vu en replay et c'était quand même
assez magnifique
cette phase de Bullet ouais quel tournoi
très très beau format
ouais ouais non effectivement il y a
beaucoup de choses trop non il y a
jamais trop parce qu'après on regarde ce
qu'on a envie de ce qu'on a envie de
voir voilà
ce qu'on a envie de regarder
donc
personnellement moi j'aime bien ce
format du champion de chaise tour j'ai
pris beaucoup de plaisir même à jouer
à le jouer à jouer la division 2 à
division 3 quand j'avais qualifié donc
c'est très sympa à jouer pour les
joueurs donc c'est souvent la clé du
truc quand c'est sympa à jouer pour les
joueurs
c'est rarement désagréable à regarder
par exemple les parties longues sont pas
forcément agréables à jouer honnêtement
il y a des il y a des il y a des coups
de moins bien quoi par des droits de
partie longue
alors il a joué G5 puis on prend puis on
prend tour C8
et ok donc il a essayé de faire j'ai 5
pourquoi il fait G5 parce que maintenant
il va amener le petit frère ça c'est sûr
H4 H5 H6 alors ton C8 attention Maxime
il dit moi aussi je suis pas plus bête
que toi si tu fais H4 est-ce que je vais
pouvoir prendre le pion ben oui parce
que H5 je vais t'encaisser le pion tu as
quand même pas trop de menaces pour
l'instant
alors certes il y a des sets qui
menacent mais il y aura autour des 8 et
maintenant on peut faire un coup de dame
par là par exemple oh mais c'est B2 ce
genre de choses et les Noirs ont l'air
quand même assez gagnant
donc pour ces 8 attaquer le pion allez
résa il est pas fou il a joué dame 4 et
pardon vous voyez à chaque fois je
remets en clair dans le cadre jouer par
airesa firugin
qui protège ce pion évidemment qui est
favori c'est très dur à dire à priori
sur le papier c'est quand même à lire
Elsa mais Maxime est tellement fort en
rapide et Blitz que c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est très très serré
c'est les
îlots vous voyez on va présenter les
joueurs ensuite j'ai pas eu le temps
mais dès que cette partie sera terminée
évidemment qu'on va présenter les
joueurs rapidement
et ces quatre jouets C4 pourquoi c'est 4
et bien tout simplement parce que ça
obstrue la dame et voyez on réattaque ce
pion à 4 c'est le bon coup d'après
l'ordinateur très très fort grosse
partie là entre les deux joueurs
français pas de cadeaux pas de cadeau
entre deux joueurs alors il s'apprécie
il se respecte il joue même des parties
en fait en tout cas à l'époque il y a
moins d'un an et je voulais partir
entraînement régulièrement quand ils
avaient quand il y avait un gros tournoi
à venir est-ce qu'ils l'ont fait cette
fois je pense pas parce que quand même
ça serait bizarre là parce qu'ils jouent
ensemble mais
et à rappeler qu'il y a le une
élimination une défaite aujourd'hui ne
signifie pas élimination c'est le fameux
double élimination et donc on reverra de
toute façon c'est de joueurs dès demain
un dans le loser bracket et l'autre dans
le winner bracket un braquet que je vais
vous montrer bientôt
mais pour l'instant place au direct G6
qui est plus rapide et puis on prend J6
et maintenant c'est très chaud on a
affaibli spion et donc en affaiblissant
spion on protège une certaine façon ce
pion parce que si on fait dame prend par
exemple si Dame prend attention c'est la
gaffe de me prendre aussi ses chèques et
c'est terminé donc après puis on prend
Jessie que va faire un lira
j'en sais rien pour l'instant mais en
tout cas
on va
on va voir ça mais
d'un projet 6 a l'air très très naturel
pour aller Raisa
est-ce que le streamer américain a fini
sa première partie je vais vous tenir au
courant au niveau des résultats que je
vais que je vais regarder tout de suite
et Magnus Carson a battu et Caro n'a
qu'à Moura il y a des pommiers abattu à
Nice guéri et
Denis lazaville quand je vais vous
présenter rapidement il est très fort il
est très fort le jeune joueur biélorus
je crois maintenant qui a fait nul
contre chakrain ma média Rohff il était
déjà qualifié pour cette division 1 il y
avait quatre joueurs qualifiés de la
précédente édition et quatre joueurs qui
sont qualifiés comme Maxime machelagrave
depuis le playing
qui a eu lieu le il y a une grosse
semaine je crois
lundi dernier une semaine une semaine
tout rond une semaine à la même heure
d'un projet 6 tours fuite
et
on s'active c'est tout à fait logique
peut-être ouais si on veut menacer en
fait de prendre un A4 c'est quand même
la clé de voûte pour faire des échecs et
c'est la clé vers le pion B2 et vers le
roi donc c'est l'objectif de Maxime à
noter qu'on peut faire tour G1
éventuellement pour qu'on peut faire
tourger un parce que sur dame prend des
6 et dame prend G7 ton F6 c'est pas
possible attention au clouage donc ton
gérer un coup qui me viendrait à
l'esprit après allez savoir dame G4
jouer attaque le pion CK il y a toujours
dans le 6 attention c'est très très
chaud on rappelle Puma et aussi un de
nos sponsor historique vous le voyez
apparaître en bas de l'écran j'ai mon
petit sweat Puma que je mettrai un de
ces jours
j'ai reçu gratuitement en plus ça fait
plaisir j'ai pas reçu les chaussures je
veux bien les chaussures
qui nous écoutent
monsieur Puma
alors
comment on fait d'un point à 4 jouer
d'un point 6 moi je suis alors il y a
nul minimum alors souvent on dit j'ai
nulle minimum mais est-ce qu'il y a
mieux bah j'ai pas l'impression alors le
coup envisager ces 17 mais des 7 ça va
faire quand même beaucoup d'échecs cette
histoire
ça va faire beaucoup d'échecs oui je
sais que je suis en échec et sur Royan
F2 matin donc c'est cher quand même on
peut pas on peut pas vraiment partir
donc attention j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a pas mieux pour et ça répète ça répète
entre les deux joueurs et ça a fait nul
ça fait nul ça répète complètement et on
va update les points
et nul dans cette première partie entre
les deux joueurs
allez raisins il part ah non allez tu as
pas le droit
là mon petit Ali resa
avec tout le respect
l'amitié que j'ai pour toi mon cher ami
tu vas pas le droit de faire ça donc on
met 0,5 on va mettre pareil pour qu'ils
sont quittés bons amis dans cette partie
les points de Maxime ça va être aussi
0,5 et voilà une belle partie très bien
joué très très chaude
et donc elle est là et ce qu'on va faire
c'est je vais déjà vous faire une petite
présentation des joueurs des forces en
présence avec 2016 avis chaque cri armée
38 ans de 1783 hiérarchie connu le
joueur azeri on voit les joueurs qui
arrivent voilà Maxime machine agrafe 32
ans en France et le rapide sur chaise
com 2775 ce qui est quand même un gros
vélo évidemment ces joueurs
sont très performants
icarbonakamura le streamer américain 35
ans États-Unis 2796
ensuite
33 ans pour Yann et pomyachi 2008 137
surchaeffecom
le roi le King norvégien le Viking
Magnus Carlson 32 ans Norvège de 1938
Ali resa le jeune presse jeune prince
français alias Mbappe 20 ans France 2817
hello à Nice Guilleri
le prince bâtard
le Baron Noir batave 29 ans Pays-Bas et
beaucoup des lots et voilà on les a vu
maintenant on regarde le bracket et on
voit on a un Magnus Carlsen qui a battu
Ikar on a camarade partie il y a des
pommiers
contre Maxime Vacher La Grave et la
zavie contre
le bracket
si on a perdu on rentre dans le looser
randoine le loser bracket là c'est plus
que des machins de parties les gagnants
continuent et on a droit de perdre une
fois dans ce tournoi et on peut toujours
se refaire tant qu'on a pas perdu deux
fois voilà c'est du 25 au 29 le format
alors ça c'est pour la la grande finale
voilà ça explique un peu tout les phases
émiation direct et tout ça artificiel
intelligence Cup et le trophée du
tournoi
popopopop qu'est-ce que c'est beau
magnifique quand même et je suis obligé
de vous mettre des pubs assez
régulièrement pour l'instant on a Maxime
avec les Noirs il part je sais pas en
combien de temps ça va recommencer mais
je vais vous le dire très certainement
rapidement
on va voir ce que ça fait on va remettre
on va remettre je vous mettre un petit
coup de pub
parce que je suis obligé c'est la loi
qui me l'oblige et je vais mettre bien
mettre les caméras voilà
on revient dans 3 minutes 5 minutes à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis donc de retour avec Ali resa
qui aura cette fois les Noirs dans cette
partie
voilà face à Maxime La Grave évidemment
pour l'instant ça revient pas je sais
pas quel est le programme exact
je fixe les caméras comme ça on a le bon
côté pour les deux joueurs
et un truc à peu près propre
je descends encore plus peut-être comme
il m'a dit
OK
ouais et la deuxième
ou la
si on le voit plus c'est pas bon ok et
voilà on a les raisins qui est là et
donc bon on a un peu de temps donc on va
peut-être aller voir finalement
le la partie entre Magnus Carlsen et
ikka en Nakamura manuscrite
Nakamura donc c'est deux joueurs qui ne
se quittent plus et on a la cavalier F3
kf6 c'est 4 B6
une West indienne tout à fait tout à
fait logique donc pour je 4
et
des 5 donc tout est tout à fait normal
le centre pour les blancs mais rien de
grave pour les Noirs quoique il aime
bien Magnus évidemment le centre les
deux fous c'est quand même sympa
normalement et des cinq joueurs
rapidement ouh là là
ça devient très très concret et ce pion
passé des
annaka qui aime bien prendre ses petits
pions d'un C3 attention la batterie sur
le pion G7
fu F6 et tourin
la MP3 il s'en sort comme ça mais dans
la finale normalement les noirs sont un
peu moins bien mais il s'en sortent et
puis on passait comme ça ça suffit pas à
gagner une partie normalement pour voir
ce qui s'est passé
c'est étonnant qu'il ait perdu ça n'a
qu'à
toujours ce pion en H6 très important ça
crée des bons scénarios avec des faux 4
coups francs G6 plus tard
et finalement même si on le perce pion
on perdra pas la partie avec les Blancs
donc c'est pas très risqué non plus
et la fois fuite qui est apparemment une
gaffe
à cause de fous des trois ok alors
pourquoi on peut pas prendre le pion je
suppose qu'il y a fou le 5 et ça ne va
pas ok
vous décide c'est là il a pris prix et
fubéen ou attention ça c'est méchant ça
c'est très méchant et on voit le
triangle de ce pion H6 faut fuite
faut 5 fois et vous prend F5 et on
encaisse le pion et on encaisse H7 très
très bien joué incroyable
incroyable ce qui s'est passé
grosse grosse partie on va voir et on a
Magnus Carlson qui a repris et donc on
va on va quand même regarder ces deux
joueurs le temps que Maxime a les
raisins reprennent donc on va changer
même de
de vue et on a ça donc F4 c'est 5 le JO
Bava system et E4 qui est quelque chose
de que naroditech ou souvent en blitz
bon Magnus devrait connaître quand même
je crois que c'est qui prend le 4 le
coup
ok on va regarder si Maxime et a les
raisins n'hésitez pas à me dire quand
Maxime a les raisins
reprennent mais c'est vrai que
normalement quand ils gagnent la
première Magnus ensuite il est quand
même très très compliqué à aller
chercher et il vient jouer qui avait
pris un 4 manuscarsen donc là c'est
cavalier comme ça qu'on a audit ski et
là il fait cavalier prend puis on prend
et
je sais plus ce qu'il fait dans des skis
peut-être qu'il fait des 5 ensuite
alors
que qui réfléchit ici bon ça c'est un
peu surprenant quand même mais bon
pourquoi pas
alors je vais essayer de changer aussi
le direct
parce que du coup
sa perte son charme
et Annie a aussi repris
et c'est assez tranchant je comprends
pas la réflexion de Nacala
il y a pas 50 coups
à mon avis elle a simplement cavalier
assise puis on a donné un pion donc
c'est quand même pas extraordinaire tout
ça donc il faut prendre il faut il faut
reprendre tout simplement
il faut reprendre il n'y a pas vraiment
d'autres choix clairement
prise il a joué qui avait 5 waouh ça
c'est une surprise quand même alors quel
était la j'ai triché un peu quelle était
la ligne analyse on va mettre les
variantes
qui prend ouais c'est ça puis on prend
et là puis on prend C5 il dit
mais des cinq des cinq est pas bon il y
a G6 donc c'est puis on prend c'est 5
mais qui avait 5 pas bon du tout
normalement
un pion de plus j'enlève le truc
mais bon il est pas convaincu très très
bizarre
si si il y a les caméras mais pour
l'instant il y a les caméras que sur
Aniche et que sur
Maxime et
à lireza vous allez les avoir regardé
Maxime qui aura les blancs dans cette
deuxième partie je pense qu'ils ont
commencé là donc je vais aller voir je
vais aller voir la camomille il va
prendre il va prendre une route dans la
deuxième aussi alors Maxime ma chaîne
qui s'en est très très bien sorti
très très bien sorti clairement
dans cette première partie nage d'orf
et là on va voir et il commence par le 4
ok ok c'est 5
et une pétrole ok un petit peu
surprenant mais allez-y il est un peu
pour ça il est très similaire à Magnus
c'est à dire qu'il peut jouer énormément
de choses moi je sens que c'est le match
du jour je l'avais dit c'est le match
aller résa Maxime le match du jour je
sors Armageddon ça pue l'armée dans
cette histoire
parce que là les deux en l'air ça rigole
pas en fait ça entre c'est pas c'est pas
la partie du dimanche entre potes alors
c'est entre joueurs qui se respecte et
justement ils veulent donner le meilleur
de même
ils ont l'air très très concentré
prêt à faire du à tout donner à ne faire
aucun cadeau
donc c'est la pétrole bon ben tout ça
est très théorique et des 7 et le coup
principal le coup qui a été joué en
match de championnat du monde parisienne
et paumé à chier face à manuscrite
tout le monde on va voir ce que va
décider de faire Maxime en général et
prendre S7 et le coup
ok ça c'est une autre ligne principale
intéressante
en forme vert encourageant pour le grand
Suisse espérons faute non un 56 on ne
sait pas mais on espère on espère
évidemment
alors que ces trois on prend ces trois
et on se retrouve dans cette position
sans cavalier en général non il fait
fout des 6 ok qui est un autre coup mais
la position sans que les dont je parlais
c'est celle là puis on prend qui est
intéressant quand même parce qu'on a on
a quand même en effet cible avec les
Blancs on peut jouer F4 F5 on a
plusieurs types de rupture donc ça reste
complètement jouable malgré tous les
cavaliers échangés
la cavalerie est changée foudez 6 jouer
par allez asafiruja qui menace tout
simplement de prendre un pur je pense
qu'on peut roquer quand même on peut
croquer parce que cavalier prend puis on
prend France rétro dangereux à cause de
toi et on est dans le coupage avec les
noirs
donc surpuis on prend on va voir ce
qu'il va faire
on va voir ce qu'il va faire notre ami
notre ami
rock ouais Maxime qui est un peu
surprises très vite
alors on peut prendre des 7 mais en
général c'est quand même pas l'idée non
ouais il fait tout pour surproté ici
attention un petit piège un tour au 8
serait pas bon du tout pourquoi tu revit
le coup naturel serait pas bon badaboum
à cause de vous prendre à 7 oui je sais
que c'est échec damage 5 quand j'ai 8
d'un prime 7 3 7 je suppose même tour
trois tours H3 devrait devrait mater en
quelque chose qu'on a pas du tout envie
de voir ici avec les
avec les Noirs même fou j'ai 5 doigts
bon même faut H6 c'est dans l'eau parce
que X 6 c'est bon pas du tout
cette recette
ouh là là
comment on finit la position là je sais
pas je vais tricher
c'est damage 5 3 G8 full G5
si on prend la lame d'un point 8 et si
on prend du pion d'un F7 fit cg6 matte
et
donc moi je suis marchait pas c'était
joli pourtant
c'est fou prends le 5 et sur pion prend
et tout simplement ok donc ça ne
marchait pas ok revenons à nos moutons
et il a joué c'est 5 qui prend des sels
il joue tout très vite le jeune
Prince Ali resa
puis on prend fou prends tout va bien
ici pour les Noirs clairement
clairement c'est confortable et surtout
il connaît il connaît la position
ça paraît damage 5 donc une menace assez
évidente on va devoir faire G6 peut-être
5 mais plutôt G6 quand même F5 semble
trop affaiblissant
ce qui me semble en tout cas
on va voir
H6 waouh mais ça s'est préparé parce
qu'on joue pas H6 aussi vite dans un tel
contexte il faut quand même regarder il
faut prendre H6 puis on prend de me
prendre on a ce mat
bon mais il y a pas 50 coups faut que
j'enlève 5 et c'est vrai que la dame
peut revenir maintenant donc ça c'est un
truc étudié à la maison
clairement la tourbe peut pas passer la
case
de la cassure à 3e et contrôlée et donc
les noirs sont très très bien
alors H6 jouez pas notre ami à
comment on va faire ici
[Musique]
bien je sais pas je sais pas ce qu'on va
faire ici
c'est pas évident pour garder de la vie
dans cette position est-ce que c'est 4
c'est 4 pour profiter de ça mais même
ces quatre je peux même faire ça c'est
ça le problème c'est que c'est pas très
grave et sur dame français 5 et puis on
prend des trois
et donc ça ne va pas donc C4 plutôt
à mettre à la poubelle
j'ai pas été un truc il montrait [__]
l'ordinateur mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
trois et intéressant
est-ce que les deux sont qualifiés 200
1/4 de finale ils peuvent pas pas
d'éliminer ce soir ça reste dans la
course ça reste dans le looser bracket
au cas où
et maintenant
comment on fait
parfois trois je vois pas trop de coups
Maxime qui a fait chier beaucoup on
n'est pas habitué du tout à ça
d'habitude plutôt à le voir mettre une
grosse pression au temps
et là il est il est sage aujourd'hui il
prend son temps
vraiment
[Musique]
il a envie de faire il pèse le poil
contre tomber un tombé un tour 5 c'est
vrai tour 5 est intéressant
effectivement très bon intervention Tera
je suppose que je fais tourner du coup
ouh là
on prend même pas et c'est maths ok ok
ok pour ça comment je fais pour protéger
mon petit pion
bien et il faut prendre 6 aussi
maintenant
est-ce qu'un coup comme ça
en mode ouais de toute façon ok j'ai un
peu de moi
mais
tu as quand même des pions c'est faible
donc je vais faire nul
donc je pense que c'est plutôt ça la
solution
et tourbé 1 qui est aussi un coup mais
tombe bien peut-être B6 faut baisser
quand même assez ok pour les noirs
huit
ok merci pour les interventions le chat
évidemment très intéressantes au 8 tout
simplement on va montrer la pointe ou un
fou F1 ça n'irait pas on aura un fou
couvert on est pas mal tout de suite
mais bon un coup comme d'hab c'est 6 ou
pas d'ailleurs
dame B5 pardon
ça n'irait pas du tout pour les blancs
cette histoire
donc on va voir ce qu'il va faire Maxime
qui prend son temps parce qu'il sait que
les Blancs normalement risque pas grand
chose dans le genre de position mais
attention
attention ça va être sympa on a quand
même VL
ouais c'est hyper tous les deux mais
attention
vu le prochain match c'est important
en gagnant ici d'accord on va mettre ça
c'est une référence au bracket où on
voit que le vainqueur de ce match joue
contre
la zavie ou ma média off et c'est vrai
que le perdant pourrait jouer Naka je
pense ouais ça croise effectivement ça
doit marcher comme ça
et on va revenir évidemment tout de
suite sur la partie qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué Maxime il réfléchit toujours fouger
5 alors ouais mais il faut que j'ai 5
menaces pas grand chose alors
effectivement on peut pas prendre ça
serait mat mais Adam G4 au minimum
au minimum
et on est complètement ok comme on l'a
vu dans ce genre de finale ça menacerait
tout à fait
donc je sais pas ce qui joue après H6
salut à toi Vincent Torg bienvenue à
tous n'hésitez pas à venir poser vos
questions dans le chat on suit ce derby
entre les deux les deux meilleurs
joueurs français un de très très loin
clairement les deux locomotives des
échecs en France
fou B2 les deux seuls joueurs à plus de
2700 Hello
vraiment les deux stars françaises fou
B2 bof bof bof j'ai envie de vous dire
ouais par des pif ou B2 hein alors il
veut évidemment un moment ou un autre je
le C4 et avoir ce fou qui joue
mais clairement ça sent que ça va pas
être
ça va pas être une réputation
ah on attend le mais ouais mais même si
Baki arrive à faire son rode de jusqu'à
2007 ça sera quand même toujours un peu
léger par rapport à Ali raisin
évidemment et Maxime qui sont des
joueurs à largement plus de 2007
pas sur le malheureusement
c'est gentil qu'est-ce que j'ai
je suis pas numéro 3 français
et c'est backy en ce moment qui a une
bonne période là
qui a quasiment 2670
donc effectivement avec Baki et Romain
Edward aussi on a on a eu 2700 mais
c'était pas hier non plus c'est il y a
quelques années déjà
2015 pour ma part ça commence à dater
j'ai très exactement 213 je crois
aller voir le top 100 des pêchez-vous
allez voir 2700s je suis
je suis
99e je crois j'étais 100e le truc c'est
pas joué
comme ça il passe derrière alors vous
b2mc 6 étoile 2
et ouais justement Jules 200643
justement qui était numéro 3 mais qui
est une expérience
devant mais bon ça se tient à pas grand
chose tout ça tandis que c'est vrai
qu'elle est loin devant et effectivement
et Maxime normalement il a simplement
simplement alors c'est vrai que pour ces
standards ça paraît très très bas
et on sent qu'il peut s'y cerner là s'il
joue comme au total il va il va gagner
des points et je joue la Coupe d'Europe
bientôt
pardon il joue l'île de Man ensuite
ça pourrait lui permettre de regagner
un élo quelques points pour pour le
replacer là où
plus convenable
un élo plus convenable à partir
je pense que si l'intro de 1750 et 2800
voilà c'est quelque chose de logique
vu son classement elle est vraiment dans
le creux de la vague ça arrive c'est
comme ça
alors c'est 6 évidemment pour sortir le
fou et tous deux on veut doubler
gentiment sachant que c'est 4 va quand
même être très dur à organiser
mais quand on va faire ensuite mais
c'est intéressant ce qui nous propose
Maxime comme d'habitude j'aime beaucoup
comment il joue c'est un étang et c'est
très intéressant ce qui fait à chaque
fois
ouais 2760 ouais ce sera hello plus
convenable on rappelle que Maxime a
largement dépassé les 2800 il a
2819 je crois au pic ou 2820
c'est quand même pas mal
c'est quand même pas mal comme pic et il
est à 100 points de ça rendez vous
compte ça fait quand même énormément ça
fait beaucoup
de 1819 ouais c'est quand même assez
hallucinant de 1819
quand on y pense
et il est quasiment 100 points de ça
donc
plusieurs d'imaginer quand même hein qui
est perdu sans point de niveau
mais il est en train de prouver
attention c'est pas rien c'est rapide
c'est pareil
ce qui peut les atteindre de nouveau ça
va être compliqué 2819 mais est-ce qu'il
peut
être compliqué honnêtement mais en 2780
oui
dame B6 attaque le fou ok là maintenant
on passe dans le jeu concret
Dali Elsa il veut dire à Maxime écoute
tu as perdu un temps tu vas pas doubler
protège ton fou maintenant tu fais quoi
avec ton fou pas mal
et on voit il pointe du doigt
quelque chose qui va pas pousser un et
oui maintenant on va plus pouvoir
doubler on va certainement sortir le fou
soit là si on considère c'est pas en
prise soit là et ensuite on va on va
doubler attention il faut prendre 6 qui
traîne toujours
donc on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
non plus salut au chat
et donc ouais intéressant alors est-ce
que sur vous aussi je vais bouger les
pièces parce que nous on a ce
qu'il faut prendre d'être une menace
ça met la pression en tout cas sur les
Noirs ça c'est certain
comment on fait je vois même pas comment
on parle le matin parce que surtout j'ai
l'impression
que ça va être le fameux mécanisme
[Musique]
qui marche
comment on fait parce que la tour
reprend aussi c'est évidemment ton
principe il y a d'un principe et ça ça
va pas parce que
je sais pas comment ça va cette histoire
échec échec
non c'est pas ça
c'est là où il y a un truc c'est ça
c'est là où il y a un truc que je rate
peut-être un coup de tout recins un truc
bizarre peut-être pour 5 ici pour amener
la tour et mater ensuite non c'est pas
ça je vais tricher
voilà décidément aujourd'hui ça ne
s'arrête pas c'est tout simplement ça
ouais ben c'est très dur et tu auras un
pour pouvoir prendre de la tour comme ça
ouais ok
pas évident mais bon toute façon ça fait
pas envie de toute façon il va pas le
faire il fait l'homme des 6 il revient
ok il va empêcher fu F4 et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il fait sur food et 2 pour
faire tout hein la question il protège
son pion aussi c'est un coup
multifonction le coup de
le coup d'Alien qui joue plus vite quand
même que que Maxime
tourner la partie ouais mais on le sent
pas Naka déjà son choix d'ouverture
était bizarre et le fameux Fuger 5 qui
menace maintenant fossette ok on peut
toujours pas prendre et à matin à 7
c'est quand même intéressant ce coup de
fouger 5 ça gagne du temps à priori
intéressant
comment on peut faire ici je trouve je
fais un peu inquiet avec les Noirs parce
que le Fou est pas sorti comment on fait
pour sortir tout ça je sais pas trop
honnêtement
ouais un coup qu'on peut oublier sous le
G5 tout à fait
tout à fait
alors comment il joue à les raisins
maintenant
je suis bien embêté moi
parce que sur un coup comme un coup de
repli je sais pas un coup qui parle à
menace
va venir par là peut-être pas ça parce
que
c'est vrai que ça met la pression quand
même tout ça faut ça t'arrive
éventuellement peut-être vous prend un 6
éventuellement donc je sais pas je
trouve ça très naturel et très facile à
jouer
pour les
pour les blancs et assez compliqué pour
les noirs
F5 c'est moche F5 c'est très moche
j'ai 6 c'est un proche 6 donc ça va pas
non plus
donc pas évident pas évident de trouver
un coup ici c'est a priori un coup de
dames et il a joué comme C6 allez-y ok
même si ça a plus de sens que mc7 ça
tient là la quasi au moins sur quand il
y aura faux 7 ça contrôlage 6 aussi et
quand il aura faux c'est quand on va
prendre on sera pas par un peu un tempo
en recette
gg30
je crois qu'ils ont plus ou moins fini
les travaux en fait tout à fait
19h ça fait un moment ça fait un moment
qu'ils sont partis quand même
et
foudé 7 si tu auras 8 dents je me moque
je rigolais j'ai vu quelqu'un sur
Youtube mettre je suppose que personne
ne travaille dans le BTP je plaisantais
évidemment
effectivement il travaille même weekend
et puis
la pénibilité c'est quand même c'est pas
évident comme comme boulot
c'est plus simple d'être commentateur de
tourner à l'échec
mais c'est vrai que ça faisait du bruit
toujours pareil
on trouve ça très bien tant que on
entend pas le bruit
alors fous des 7
et quand on prépare les JO à Paris
attention
on peut jouer faux c'est ouais on peut
jouer
et jouer tout au 8 je suppose et c'est
tout liquider
et ça a l'air d'aller ça manque de ouais
du coup faudrait un super coup pour
jouer super court très logique coup de
développement pour jouer tout va vite
faut c'est un pour jouer C4 ça va être
trop lent à mon avis
parce que je vais avoir tout 8
entre-temps et ces quatre j'aurais
toujours des cadeaux de toute façon
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait notre ami
Maxime il a joué F4
il recule son fou quelle est son idée je
n'en sais rien surtout au 8 qui va
certainement apparaître sur votre
échelle c'est quand même l'idée il y a
une seule colonne ouvert donc a priori
on va la contester cette colonne en
jouant une des deux tours en 8 je sais
pas laquelle d'ailleurs peut-être ton F
maintenant que le pion F7 est plus en
prise ça permet aussi de de pouvoir
mettre de foin fit et qui va jouer full
5 Maxime c'est assez probable même
ouais alors
le chat qui nous dit que Maxime peut
être moins bien dans quelques coups
c'est pas c'est pas excluche mais je
trouve quand même il y a une certaine
sécurité dans la position des blancs
mais effectivement concrètement la
structure est quand même assez faible et
par exemple les finales de fou ça aurait
quand même archi nul
quoi
ça serait pas archi nul mais faudrait
avoir le temps de mettre le fond en des
quatre et là ça serait mieux assez
facilement
donc ça manque de cavalier pour attaquer
pour attaquer les faiblesses mais
effectivement ça peut ça peut tourner
alors ça c'est peu probable mais c'est
pas impossible non plus je suppose je
sais pas moi mon réflexe ça serait de
passer à une
un liquidation massive des forces en
présence
mais
allez savoir
ce qu'il y a mieux à faire
je ne sais pas en tout cas
il pense que non
va certainement arriver
je suppose
ça joue pour le chaos pas tellement 4
nuls
moi je sens les quatre nuls et
l'Armageddon
mais des nuls compatibles des nuls comme
on aime voir
les deux joueurs là qui
la première partie est intéressante
celle-là aussi
est-ce qu'on peut faire tour 8 où on n'a
pas besoin
c'est pas pressé
mais pourquoi pas je vois pas vraiment
l'inconvénient de jouer pour 8 après on
peut être plus ambitieux en essayant de
[Musique]
mettre un peu la pression sur ses pions
c'est quoi que je vois pas exactement
comment et de toute façon il y aura 5
donc
[Musique]
pour 8 en échange puis d'un F5 ok moi
même ça donc effectivement ça menace un
échec je peux certainement faire G6 et
X8
ça a l'air d'aller
bien sûr twitch alors sur Youtube toi
maintenant
jouer
on va voir je pense que j'ai 6 va
arriver un quoi d'autre attention
donc comment on fait ici avec les noirs
on va faire G6 c'est jouer dame 5 fois 8
et ça paraît quand même très très solide
cette histoire pour les Noirs attention
menace full G7 faites vous pensez 3 et
d'un E3 petit coup de frein là de Maxime
qui attaque H6 qui attaque à 7 double
attaque mais il a C3
il faut mettre un coup de frein là il
faut faire attention
ça reste solide évidemment mais
attention quand même plus attention pour
les blancs finalement
pour les blancs clairement
après il y a un truc concret
si je fais H5 par exemple j'ai
l'impression que le pion va être
comestible
quoi que quoi que ici ici
tout simplement
il a joué à 6 ah il est malin il est
malin il est malin comme tout parce que
sur
ces trois et ma foi c'est très très
équilibré tout ça mais je crois que
c'est ce que va faire Maxime parce que
il peut faire faux 5 aussi qui est très
solide mais pourquoi faut faire
attention avec les avec les Blancs là
ça ça a quand même ça favorise les
perpettes clairement donc dame prend on
va faire dames 3
certainement quelque chose comme ça et
on va tenter à perpète
une proposition de nulle silence
silencieuse
c'est un format dans quelle furgea
serait plus à ce que ML ouh là là rien
n'est moins sûr là les deux joueurs sont
tellement à l'aise on va voir le pari
qui vont faire les deux avec le nombre
de minutes
ça sera intéressant
donc on rappelle le format de la magdon
15 minutes pour les blancs
et
un nombre de minutes à définir pour les
noirs avec le on peut faire nul et il y
a une mise aux enchères des noirs
donc les deux joueurs font évidemment
une enchère privée c'est à dire que je
l'ai fait moi aussi quand j'ai joué
c'est tournoi on envoie directement à
l'arbitre qui est là qui est dans le col
l'arbitre qui fait aussi le en petite
cheating check avec les deux avec les
deux caméras une devant une derrière qui
demande de faire un tour de la salle
alors évidemment
ça ne peut jamais tout éviter mais quand
même ça permet de jouer rassurer et
clairement il y a aucun doute sur sur
les joueurs
ça c'est c'est évident H4 jouer par
Maxime Vacher la grave
ok sur dame français 3 il veut faire un
H5 toujours ambitieux Maxime attention
de pas s'en mordre les doigts
parce que par exemple je vois pas très
bien comment il fait
je sais pas trop ce qu'il fait sur H5
on va voir mais en tout cas c'est la
phase critique de 40 pour 3-20
le fouet 8 est en l'air effectivement
bien joué bienvenue
William prend ces trois il y a pas d'âme
prend ces trois
et c'est pour ça que je fous des 7
d'ailleurs
notre ami airesa donc maintenant en fait
ce qui veut dire c'est qu'il veut faire
pour un 6 maintenant si je comprends
bien la logique
h 5G 5 fois 5
jouable aussi
mais je vois pas
l'attaque de maths je la vois pas trop
quand même pour les blancs
très honnêtement
qu'est-ce que ça donne cette histoire ah
ça c'est pas bon parce que
ok ok ok faire une offre
pourquoi c'est la pendule et à jour mvl
donc je suppose que faut prendre à me
prend et de me prendre ces trois va
arriver
dans ces trois tout de suite et un coup
aussi mais je vois pas l'intérêt
je prendrai pour essayer de faire des
perpettes après
manus en train de perdre mais non
mais non
donc on va voir on va peut-être un
retour de Nakamura
c'est de là sont assez incroyables vous
savez qu'on aimerait voir les deux les
deux matchs mais bon
on peut pas être partout
alors il empêche ce coup de dame 5 et il
menace un petit menace dame débute échec
évidemment il sait très bien qu'elle
irait voir ça mais c'est un moyen de
remplacer la dame
et peut-être à 5 arrive
à moins il n'a qu'à moi il y a une
partie très intéressante entre carsel et
Nakamura
je vais vous montrer ça rapidement allez
rapidement c'est la position entre
Carcès et Nakamura
ou ouais c'est ça en fait il a proposé
nul nul entre manuscrit Nakamura
pourquoi regardez c'est très joli de fou
de fou contre ça ne passe pas c'est trop
solide ça pour les noirs
mais bon ça gagne pas
OK et donc on va revenir à nos moutons
et à la partie de
donc
son match face au streamer américain
forteresse et oui crois pas au
forteresse mais bon
quand ça l'arrange ça l'arrange
alors vous pouvez 5 pour échanger tout
ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire [__]
puis on prend si on joue bêtement
j'essaie de quelqu'un avant de bête et
méchante dame prend dame prend ces deux
ouais ça va faire nul
ça a très certainement fait à faire nul
on pouvait faire ça aussi qui était
mieux certainement ça c'est beaucoup
plus solide beaucoup plus facilement nul
il faut prendre puis on prend il fait H5
Maxime va chez agrave il attaque ici il
y a toujours pas de perpète ici
il joue sans risque Maxime il a bien
raison
parce que c'est vrai que sur dame en
roue H2 on souffre quand même ici on va
souffler en cette finale alors
on va faire nul mais c'est quand même
les blancs qui sont du meilleur côté de
la nul clairement
parce que ça donne
est-ce que va nous proposer notre ami
amiresa oula il est parti
ça veut dire que la partie est terminée
il y a une minute de décalage
donc on va voir la fin de la partie mais
a priori
[Musique]
a priori il y a une île où on sait pas
dame prend ses deux jouets
ah il prend le pion ouais tout
simplement
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Maxime
[Musique]
c'est ma
supposition
ouais
va être joué suite d'un F4 et nul comme
ça pas répétition ok
à proposition de nul après d'un point de
5 31e coup ok accepter
par Ali raza qui allait de toute façon
prendre la nul ok
belle nulle de combat
et qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les
autres matchs on a
ma média off qui joue encore contre
l'asavik
et qui a fait nul on va faire un petit
tour du côté du bracket
et on voit mon escla 5 qui mène un
ennemi 0 et demi face anaka un épaule de
0 contre guéri fil rouge à lâché la
Grave un partout et ça joue toujours
entre la zavik et
ma média Rohff
je vais peut-être vous montrer ça
non
on va mettre ça le liveboard hop là on
voit le RCX dans nos partenaires
comme opéra
chez moi j'en ai deux chez moi j'ai deux
boîtiers regardez
voilà qui mesure la qualité de l'air à
domicile et on voit Magnus Carson qui
est 723 de CO2 de taux de CO2 ppm
bien c'est c'est trop normalement
l'idéal c'est 400 500 mais bon jusqu'à
1000 c'est pas très grave après il faut
s'organiser
bon on voit cette partie entre la zavie
qui est ma média off écoutez c'est à peu
près équilibré
ce qu'on va faire c'est quand Maxime
aura les
Maxime ah c'est une gaffe après la chose
qui a un jeune joueur biélorusse très
très dangereux
placement de produit merci
et dans ces 7 jours sur le clouage ça se
passe mal pour
pour notre ami
[Musique]
oula c'était quoi le début c'était un
Gambie de la dame mais alors façon H4
intéressant H4 il fait 6 bon pourquoi
pas
mais laservic qui a réussi à résoudre
ses problèmes assez facilement
et qui est même qui est en train de
prendre le dessus
pas du tout ça va faire nul ok donc on
va se mettre
la partie 3
la partie 2
ça revient bien tôt Maxime aura les
noirs
on va le on va le déplacer à
pour l'instant on voit pas
et on va descendre tout ça
ok ok et donc
[Musique]
voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe on va
regarder un partout
entre les deux joueurs français
intéressantes intéressantes et parties
clairement et
[Musique]
vraiment ça joue tout simplement
manuscrit
qui mène face à Nakamura et demi 500
euros si pour guéri de zéro pour dépôt
et la zavik m'avait des Rohff un partout
on le rappelle c'est au meilleur des
quatre parties ces matchs et on verra de
toute façon les deux joueurs demain donc
mais on va voir on va suivre avec
intensité et un grand intérêt ce match
entre les deux joueurs dans la prochaine
maximum
et on va faire un petit break commercial
qui vous permet de souffler aussi aux
commentateurs de souffler et qui est
complètement obligatoire pardon
petite pub
et voilà je reviens à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour pour ce
artificial intelligence Scop
l'écart de finale on a les faces ko
entre
[Musique]
entre manuscrit Nakamura mais le match
qu'on suit évidemment c'est le grand
format du jour c'est
Maxime va chier la grave contre Ali resa
firuga et vous voyez les deux joueurs
qui vont bientôt reprendre
allez la bonté de remettre sa caméra il
attend
il est en short
profité pour fermer la fenêtre je
reviens dans 30 secondes
c'est beaucoup plus chaud si on perd
et Maxime donc qui est là mais pour
l'instant pas de partie
et c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent se
rencontrer je pense je pense qu'ils
peuvent se rendre rencontrer en finale
si jamais voilà si jamais ce les deux
gagnent leur
bracket ensuite le tableau des
vainqueurs et le tableau des
perdants on va voir si une partie
reprend pour l'instant
elle a signalé sauf chez Magnus Carson
on va suivre un petit peu Magnus du coup
non c'est pas là c'est là voilà donc
face à au streamer américain j'ai pas le
temps de mettre des caméras aujourd'hui
pour les deux joueurs mais dès demain
tout sera au point cavalier F3 jouer par
Magnus Carlsen
donc on verra un loser bracket c'est
possible qu'il joue à 17h et donc c'est
pas impossible que je prenne l'antenne
demain à 17h faut voir tout ça peut-être
c'est 18h tous les jours de toute façon
alors KF3 kfc4 c'est reparti pour ça et
D6 de la part de Naka qui est mené un
ennemi 0,5
et donc effectivement
et bien c'est quand même
[Musique]
ah ben voilà on a ça c'est quand même
l'heure d'essayer de revenir
qui est C3 joué par
Magnus Carlsen est-ce qu'on va voir une
instinienne une vieille indienne
de la part du carreau qui réfléchit là
qui essaie d'avoir une position vivante
mais ça ne va pas être évident
évidemment je vais surveiller d'un œil
le retour de Maxime et à l'IRESA
ok plein de coups ici mais j'ai 6 a
priori le plus le plus logique
et G6 joué par e-caru Nakamura
E4 pour ensuite suivre avec des 4
certainement
et menacé qui va arriver une
installienne et sur l'échiquier on va
avoir quel système il joue Magnus il
joue faut deux ok la classique est-ce
qu'il va faire le 5
Naka qui allait une principale après il
y a plein de coups cavaliers assis et
BD7 même si 5 existe c'est 6
et dans le coup mais c'est vrai que
normalement vous fougère
E5 et après 5 rock il y a encore
énormément de coups il y a C6 ici puis
on prend des quatre cavaliers à 6 même
tour 8 j'ai vu chez erdon Van forest
récemment H6 et regga easy
bref énormément de coups
et de d'options pour les deux joueurs et
joue cavaliers à 6
IKA una kamura
c'est pas la variante qui est la
meilleure réputation mais bon pourquoi
pas petit rock joué et sur 5 il va très
certainement faire faux 3 manuscrits et
aussi un coup on va voir faux 3 jouer
par Magnus
et maintenant encore une fois et dans
notre coup pour les Noirs dames 8
c'est 6
que j'ai 4
faut j'ai 5 dames 8 ça c'est une vieille
variante
très intéressante pour les Noirs ici
mais on peut prendre le 5 aussi c'est
très raisonnable de prendre le 5
alors est-ce que
non mais pour a repris contre Aniche
et nepo qui mène de zéro contre niche
donc ça va pas être simple pour notre
ami à Nice
et jouer 5 échec assez rapidement
logique
les experts me comprendront donne quoi
les Français il y a un partout pour
l'instant entre les deux Français ça va
reprendre bientôt
on a beau match mais c'est vrai que les
parties reprennent petit à petit
manuscrit réfléchit ici
une ligne très populaire en début des
années 2000 mais c'est vrai que ça a
perdu de sa popularité
pour les Noirs c'était plutôt plutôt pas
facile pour les Noirs ici dans cette
ligne donc vraiment qui est censé
censé réfuter on met le Para futé mais
en tout cas poser de gros problèmes au
noir
on met en cas vis-à-vis entre la tour et
la dame
intéressante on va voir ce qu'il va
faire effet puis on prend le 5 ou plus
conservateur de la part de
[Musique]
de Wagner puis on prend puis on prend et
dames C1 alors ça c'est un peu étonnant
OK
intéressant on arrive à tout on enlève
la dame de la de la colonne ouverte on
va certainement mettre la tour peut-être
H3 pour empêcher cavalier H6 aussi ça
peut être intéressant c'est que sur F6
ou D2
se retrouve plus ou moins pris au piège
on menaçage 3 ici
intéressant un petit coup je vais par
Magnus qui a toujours une culture très
complète des ouvertures
il connaît énormément de choses
comment on fait ici avec les Noirs c'est
pas très clair et c'est vrai que sur H6
on fait fout des deux aussi on va
menacer H3 et de prendre ce pion H6 donc
c'est intéressant comme concept ce coup
de damser de la part de manuscrite
dit oui en
courage évidemment Marc Andréa qui est
sorti pour l'instant le champion du
monde junior attention il y a 11 rondes
c'est 5 rondes 4 et demi sur 5 il a mis
le point d'avance sur énormément de
joueurs à 4 sur 5 mais quand même c'est
un excellent début de tournoi à suivre
pour les plus courageux pendant la nuit
et Maxime et a les raisins en repris
donc on va voir tout de suite évidemment
on va venir vers nos deux champions
français
voilà ici et
là bas est-ce qu'il y a eu un chicken
shakes club le dernier c'est le 66e
a été enregistré
j'ai mon cher ami qui pose la question
dans chat il a été enregistré il y a pas
longtemps samedi il est sorti le
dimanche je crois
donc hier
donc tu peux l'écouter
alors on a encore et pas trop
normalement le temps de se préparer
entre deux rondes quoi que et là il y a
des breaks plus importants que division
d'eau Division 3
pour les besoins de la télé norvégienne
et on voit la répétition
de la ligne de la première partie grand
rock B5 à 3 x 7 3 B1
tomber évidemment faut B7 tout ça est
très connu sous des trois H6 fois h4k et
c'est 5 et if5 c'est le premier à dévier
à lire les infiruja il avait pris en C5
dans la première partie puis on prend
ces 5 et 5 mais il y avait pas obtenu
grand chose il joue F5 cette fois bon il
est évidente c'est évidemment de prendre
et de jouer éventuellement 5 peut-être
fou j'ai 6
donc attention Maxime qui connaît très
très bien ses positions évidemment qu'il
est jouent merveilleusement bien
tu l'as raté flow 1995 aucun problème
hein merci c'est gentil fin du chicken
shakes club bon on sait pas on sait pas
trop où on va avec le Chicken mais bon
c'est vrai qu'il annonce que c'est le
dernier mais effectivement à chaque fois
ce qui est une semi blague non ce qui
est une blague mais bon on sait jamais
un jour ça sera vrai
salut tata j'ai
pas encore sur Spotify
ça je sais pas ça c'est notre community
manager qui s'en occupe
moi j'écoute pas les podcasts sur
Spotify j'ai pas du tout la ref
aire en général je vais pas voir
mais bizarre parce que normalement en
tout cas c'est sur Youtube avec la vidéo
si vous voulez voir nos jolis minois
alors F5
aurait pu jouer le championnat du monde
junior il est né en 2003 donc c'était sa
dernière année comme junior ce qui fait
quand même ce qui est assez incroyable
bon maintenant faut avouer que
le champion du monde junior a pas le
même prestige que
qu'avant casse pas en fait et champion
du monde junior car pas aussi
donc on voit que les meilleurs joueurs
du monde jouer ça Magnus n'a pas été
champion du monde
n'a pas été champion du monde junior
belle coupe de Peter Haye pas assez
commenté c'est vrai exact passé commenté
et belle coupe
mais Mexique quand même merci sympa
donc ouais c'était tout à fait ça avait
un autre prestige il faut l'avouer ce
championnat du monde junior il y a mais
bon c'est que ça reste quand même titre
c'est exceptionnel qui a eu de français
je vais le tien il a gagné
à 15 ans je crois et Maxime a chez
Lagrave la gagner en 2009
donc
ça risque calme toi majeur du calendrier
international et c'est une ligne à son
palmarès attention
c'est quand même une très très belle
ligne
alors il prend Maxime OK
allez hasard réfléchis pour reprendre
parce qu'il peut faire que les Français
5 maintenant on pourrait pas prendre du
pion là si on prend du pion je pense
qu'on perd
j'allais dire qu'on perd à cause de ça
mais
et sur cinq comment on fait
sur le 5 on a embêté un petit peu
mais probablement on peut aller là
et finalement un peu tout liquider un
peu comme dans la première et je vais le
petit rock et tout va bien
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici
on prend le coup vraiment très logique
mais ça ouvre la diagonale du four alors
peut-être on prend pas tout de suite on
Roque simplement et on va mettre la tour
en 8 et tout a l'air de bien aller pour
les noirs
tout simplement quand Maxime il comprend
pas il prend mais voilà c'est une bonne
stratégie est-ce que je peux prendre ici
et comme ça je joue sur l'échec je fais
chèque ici ça pose une petite question
mais simplement faut cinq à l'air fort
bon apparemment il voyait mieux que ça
peut-être dame 7 pour proposer la petite
finale la peur de fou non plus marrant
ça serait pas raisonnable et c'est pour
ça qu'elle Raisa a joué qu'elle prend
ses 5 puis on prend C5 jouer par Maxime
va chez La Grave à tempo
alors
comment on fait ici avec les Blancs
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce bleu
ceux qui sont sur YouTube à vous abonner
aux chaînes twitch cheescom FR ou chaîne
Youtube pour évidemment nous soutenir
c'est pas grand chose
mais
pour nous ça veut dire beaucoup
donc n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce un
like un abonnement et comme ça vous êtes
notifié à chaque fois qu'il y a un
événement alors comment on fait ici vous
pouvez suivre les meilleurs joueurs du
monde et les meilleurs joueurs français
en alien Reza ici camp de Maxime si
c'est pas beau un match en quatre
parties en rapide
magnifique
comment on fait maintenant soit 5 soit
puis on prend F5 puis on prend pas la
RTI parce qu'il y a aucun
et fougez trois c'est rien du tout il y
a fout des 6
c'est le problème
et au 5 je pense que cavalier au 4 quand
même est nécessaire on peut pas on peut
pas laisser des choses comme ça par
exemple
ça va ça va aller trop vite un problème
le cavalier par exemple sur Cay prend 5
jours et tourner 7 ici
et ça a l'air d'être tout de suite tout
de suite terminé sur quel prend des
septième à me prendre 7 et chaque et mat
donc ça ne va pas
donc à mon avis le coup c'est vraiment
c'est E5 pardon
papillon F5 je sais pas quoi il
réfléchit malheureusement
si j'étais plus fort je le saurai
le score c'est pas plutôt à partout
pardon j'ai oublié de changer le score
merci de me le rappeler
merci de me rappeler un peu partout
évidemment
et
un partout excusez-moi autant pour moi
au temps pour moi
comment il veut faire ici aller à Elsa
on rappelle le match le gain du match à
deux nuits donc on aura forcément une
quatrième partie puis on prend le 5 a
été joué ça j'aime pas trop petit rock
je joue à tempo par Maxime donc
finalement c'est un peu l'histoire de
l'arroseur arroser avec aliasa qui
essaie de surprendre mais Maxime qui a
réfléchit une minute une minute 30 qui a
très très bien
réagi et qui donc obtient une position
très confort je trouve avec les Noirs
peut-être B4 c'est 4 on va jouer tour 8
attaque des blancs elle est pas
forcément évidente j'ai 4 va être
compliqué
parce qu'il y a toujours cette tour en
H1 qui est qui est en l'air
et donc pas évident pour les blancs de
savoir comment on fait
faut prendre V5 waouh c'était ça qui
voulait et surtout on prend un dessin
qui a fougé 3 et ben alors ça c'est un
truc que j'aurais pas du tout vu vous
voyez parce que la dame est attaquée
maintenant elle peut pas garder le
contrôle avec le fou parce que la tour
contrôle les cases et ensuite on va
reprendre le fou OK
quelle vision tactique de la part
d'aller résa qui en profite pour prendre
un petit coup d'eau là alors
effectivement ça peut donner le pion ici
ça peut ouvrir la colonne mais c'est un
pion attention ces joueurs là il faut
pas laisser traîner
alors maintenant comment on fait avec
les Noirs pas évident
pas évident de savoir ce qu'on fait ici
c'est pas du tout parce que alors ça
permet d'attaquer mais
ça reste quand même ça ouvre j'ai
l'impression que ça ouvre des
perspectives pour être honnête après
peut-être un truc comme ça
ça
donne c'est hyper hyper compliqué
surtout j'ai trois fautes il y a pas fou
pour un V5 échec ah oui avant
ouais il est fort il est là mais alors
peut-être raté par Maxime il faut
prendre le 5 je sais pas on n'a pas vu
sa tête quand quand aller-retza la jouer
mais c'est pas le genre de coup même
même s'il perd le pion il y aura
toujours du jeu sur la colonne vert donc
c'est pas forcément très grave
le plus grave dans cette histoire c'est
qu'on peut pas faire tout 8 pour
protéger parce que ça contrôle la case
de 8 c'est peut-être ça le plus grave au
final
alors après on met 5 non non on fait pas
qu'elle est propre on fait fou j'ai
trois clairement
clairement et on attaque un peu tout
c'est vrai que ça va être alors l'ordi
est pas impressionné
bon bon
il est pas facilement impressionnable
je vais tricher je triche en direct dams
ce que je comprenais pas sur M6 ça me
prend un set ok ça je comprends la tour
8 ok il y a du jeu c'est évident parce
qu'il y a des deux en l'air il y a des 4
qui menacent ouh là là
et fait tout faire sauter et surtout
prends V8 par contre je comprends pas il
y a tout revu
alors là bonne chance et la B4 l'ordi
dit que les noirs sont mieux
mais alors ouais effectivement il y a du
jeu mais c'est une qualité un pion quand
même
bon et bien donc surtout prends mes cinq
il faut jouer après en V5 tout
simplement
est-ce qu'il va le trouver
c'est je trouve ça extrêmement dur mais
bon c'est son royaume
c'est le royaume de Maxime Vacher la
grave
parce que
je vois pas dans quel monde c'est bien
pour les blancs
ça m'a l'air vraiment pas terrible
donc et l'ordinateur a l'air de
d'être d'accord et ça peut-être rater un
parallérésent c'est facilement rentable
ça serait incroyable s'il trouve ça mvl
mais il est tellement incroyable dans
cette position que c'est pas impossible
l'idée de jouer P4 ensuite il prend son
temps encore une fois il a bien raison
les deux joueurs qui aurait pu jouer
dans la même pièce ils sont à Paris tous
les deux
mais bon chacun chez soi
chacun chez soi et tout va bien
donc
faut prendre 5
on va voir quoi d'autre
est-ce que vous prendrez encore un petit
peu parce que là les ventes sont trop
compliquées B4
et sur fouget3 il y a dame B7 à mon avis
donc pas fou G3 mais cavaliers E4 ici
mais allez savoir
allez savoir ce que ça donne c'est archi
compliqué mais je pense que ce sont les
deux options clairement on peut pas se
permettre de enfin on peut se permettre
mais bon
on peut se permettre de donner le pion
mais ça serait moins bon comme vous
c'est 8 pour essayer de profiter de la
colonne B mais là je vais simplement je
suppose que je vais faire Fougères
qu'on menace où j'ai trois
donc oui peut-être par par défaut en
fait il faut être obligé de faire ça
donc je sais pas
on va voir on va voir ce que fait Maxime
mais en tout cas il prend son temps
et
il prend son temps
[Musique]
Maxime voir ce qu'il va faire
mais je crois que au final il va se
résoudre et finalement peut-être qu'il
va trouver par élimination c'est c'est
souvent comme ça on trouve pas
humiliation les
les bons coups
les caméras sont figées
c'est pas impossible
j'ai fait une boulette
les caméras étaient figées pardon
j'avais fait une sacrée boulette
qu'est-ce que je vous dise
bonjour ou pas
il bouge pas beaucoup quand même hein
comment ça se fait que
je comprends rien ah non il a bougé
pour
un truc avec la caméra en tout cas
ok bon un petit coup de riz fraîche à
l'ancienne
bug chrono aussi oh on va décidément ça
ne s'arrête pas alors
ça y est on est revenu il a joué
pour gérer il a pas trouvé ce pion 3 V5
mais c'est très très dur
c'était très très compliqué de trouver
ça
toujours est maintenant il va prendre
très certainement quoi d'autre fu F3
est-ce que ça serait bon faut F3
apparemment c'est vraiment pas bon
pourquoi faut G3 je suppose j'ai 3 allez
très dangereux ou pas
ou pas certainement tourner trois alors
attaque le fou
et menace d'aller en G3 ensuite pourquoi
faut j'ai trop marché pas on va regarder
quand même j'ai trois dames simplement
et surtout prends V8 en même temps
attaque le fou on peut pas prendre il y
a B2 on attaque des 1 on attaque tout ça
n'allait pas du tout
donc tour G1 jouer par Ali Reza
on va prendre ici parce qu'on est obligé
550 pour Maxime va chez La Grave
et bien
il mange
il a besoin il a besoin de force
vous allez prendre des forces il y a
bien raison
il s'est empiffre pas de saucisson moi
j'ai déjà vu sans pile frais de
saucisson dans c'est
non non c'est match la banane c'est plus
sportif quand même
alors tourgé un fou B7 est-ce qu'on fait
fou B7 ou pas
non plus on prend un
allez 4
ouais alors c'est évident c'est évident
c'est évident moi ça me semble pas
évident beca de jouer et voilà la bande
qu'on voyait est-ce que vous pouvez F6
c'est un point que je voulais aborder
avec vous est-ce que vous pouvez F6 vous
prend qui est des 5 mois qui me semble
tentant
et bon ou pas
d'après la jauge non
moi je suis tenté évidemment à chaque
fois de d'échanger j'ai l'impression la
finale est quand même pas terrible pour
les Noirs c'est ce qui me semblait non
au minimum à 4 peut-être c'est le
cavalier est assez fort parce que cette
qualité 6 pas de dangereux quand même
pour les noirs
mais apparemment donc faut protéger ce
fou donc a priori d'AMS c'est 6
et tout va bien pour les Noirs
effectivement c'est chaud
donc après B4 quels sont les options
l'autre option est cavalier 4
comment on fait on fait pour faire
qu'elle prend
de me prendre mais ça c'est un dangereux
quand même on a peut-être pour ranger
cette peut-être F6 peut-être d'un point
H6
surpuis on prend un 3 en maths
comment va-t-on
on va mater
dame là
rien du tout et on va être mal dans
quelques coups
on peut pas arrêter la taxe blanche
donc on voit le potentiel quand même des
deux donc 4 est vraiment un très bon
coup faut trouver des mots 5 après je
crois la ligne qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
c'est Dame 5
ok c'est trouvable mais bon
c'est trouve un Magnus et gagnant
apparemment
allez on va faire un petit tour chez le
champion du monde
ah le champion du monde voilà ma langue
est fourché j'ai l'ancien chez l'ancien
triple
qu'est-ce qui se passe chez ancien
triple ouh là là il gagne du matériel là
j'ai l'impression
ce qui est gagnant on peut tout
simplement prendre et jouer cavalier 4
ou pas c'est quoi la ligne
c'est cavalier H5 sur X5 et dames 5 bons
pieds bon œil de la part de manus
Carlsen et cavalier au 7 à la fin ok
donc ça gagne a priori pour manuscrit
qui me dit déjà un demi-heure et demi
donc ça pourrait être la fin du match
mais on revient évidemment chez nos
frenchy qui nous offre un très beau
spectacle depuis le début de la journée
et cette partie peut aller dans les deux
sens clairement 650 contre 5 20
après simplement 21 coups mais qu'elle
est complexe cette night of
les deux joueurs n'ont pas peur
champion du monde de partir rapidement
tout à fait un titre qui en mettra en
jeu à la fin de l'année
ou pas d'ailleurs on sait pas s'il y a
mais il adore ça il adore les rapides et
Blitz mais en tout cas ça domination est
quand même incontestable évidemment il a
remis les choses au clair entre la Coupe
du monde le speech les tournois online
il gagne il gagne quand il joue tout
simplement
ces derniers temps c'est assez
impressionnant
mais alien réservé qui joue au jeu de
Maxime attention alors c'est peut-être
pour se tester aussi
jouer je me rappelle d'un match perdu
par Magnus Carlsen face à
mvl nota à Londres un parti longue et
partir rapide comme ça où il voulait se
tester donc jouer sur les points forts
de Maxime jouer sur Sunrise
des mauvais tours il a perdu ce match là
donc attention de pas tester trop Maxime
sur ses points forts parce que c'est
point forts sont très forts mais c'est
aussi la marque des grands de vouloir
défier
son adversaire sur ses points forts
et après tout ça reste effectivement il
y a un enjeu très clairement
financier mais
bon ça reste c'est pas mal champion du
monde non plus
ça reste un tournoi important évidemment
avec énormément de prix
mais
voilà on peut on peut tester des choses
plus que plus que pour un tournoi des
candidats ou le droit de l'île de Man
par exemple
salut kaxor
alors qu'est-ce qui va nous faire à
lireza il hésite entre fou prend et
entre fous prend c'est ça c'est les deux
coups j'en vois pas d'autres
et cavaliers
ou pas ou pas ou pas
on regarde toujours on m'a toujours là
et on va toujours
on m'a toujours et donc c'est quoi le
coup de
non papillon
tu reprends un G7 échec on va prendre un
G7
et ça me donne rien donc c'est le
premier coup à regarder évidemment mais
ça permet de marcher F6 peut-être j'ai 6
maintenant un truc peut-être tourage 5
est-ce que tu rage 5 c'est ma toile puis
on prend H5 dames K3 je suis tes tours
G7 tactique Fraisse
on est là on est là quand même un petit
peu
mais ouais des jolies lignes et ça se
voit que c'est dangereux
comment il va faire à l'IRESA 3,40
attention les raisins quand même
attention à pas je vérifie où en est
Magnus Carsen et manuscar c'est toujours
complètement gagnant quand c'est parti
contre Karuna les pas voir rester avec
moi et c'est complètement gagnant ça va
être terminé ça va être un deux et demi
zéro et demi pour
notre ami Magnus face à Naka alors après
c'est pas fini ouh là il y a un an je
sais Skype on voit les gens qui ont
souscrit à la chaîne n'hésitez pas à en
faire de même
ouais Master Class de Magnus mais bon
c'est dur des qui mènent dans ces matchs
il est très dur parce que il est noir il
est tellement solide que les joueurs
essayent de de prendre des risques avec
les noirs
et donc ça il y a le retour de bâton
alors B4 qu'est-ce qui se passe un
message dans ce lac que se passe-t-il
OK
alors
on va
Dame Blanche géant non il a fait dames
blanches géant je crois que ça marchait
pas du tout Dame Blanche j'avais pensé
mais il y a plus en français 3
et le problème c'est qu'on ne menace
absolument rien les tours j'ai eu de va
arriver c'est terminé oui aussi la
contre-attaque donc il a joué cavalier
E4 un coup un des trois coups candidats
qu'on avait vu
peut-être le plus prometteur qui est des
5 mois je préfère comme ça on regarde la
tour c'est mon côté peureuse mon côté
lâche je veux garder une tour sur la sur
la première rangée au lieu de
l'embarquer là sur la 5e
donc cavalier 4 jouer
par
un
j'ai trop hâte c'est aussi intéressant
mais il faut G3 dame B7 je pense j'ai
trois
dame B7 certainement attaque la tour
menace puis on prend C3 ça va faire trop
sur faut prendre V8 je pense qu'il y a
même il y a ça attention gagne du
matériel ça va pas du tout donc cavalier
4 jouer maintenant quoi d'autre dame 5
était le meilleur coup d'après la jauge
mais alors attention
il faut être accroché pour jouer d'âme 5
mais bon en même temps on joue pas l'âge
d'or enfin si on joue si on envisage pas
du coup comme dame 5 on ne joue on fait
autre chose on joue le Berlin
je trouve je donne un jeu trop facile
avec trop de menaces pour les blancs
je pense qu'il y a joué dans le sac
Maxime
maintenant
on n'aime pas qu'est-ce qu'on aime pas
on a un
sur ça on fait ça c'est ça
donc non on n'aime pas ça on aime bien
la même 5 par contre 5 centralisation si
ça marche c'est le coup qu'il faut jouer
Maxime qui réfléchit
on va voir
et boit de l'eau aux bananes
le nouveau régime de Max et il a pris
il a pris en 4
alors petit décalage entre la caméra des
joueurs que j'ai en live et les
chéquiers qu'on a avec une minute de
moins bon donc c'est pour ça qu'on le
voit jouer un coup en même temps qui qui
loue sa bouteille d'eau
il n'est que gaucher il n'est pas
ambidextre mvl quoi que c'est pas sûr
peut-être que je raconte des bêtises en
plus
j'ai l'impression qu'il
je crois qu'il écrit avec la main droite
OK
dame prend il faut prendre et on a cette
position ou d'un mec si c'est une énorme
menace attention ouais 7 jours
pas d'angoisse chez mvl surtout cher il
va faire tourner 8 et il dit bah je suis
pas angoissé moi même pas peur
alors est-ce que les raisins faudrait
pas un petit coup de défense là un petit
coup de A4 pour être c'est le coup
d'angoisse et une nouvelle fois ce qu'on
se dit quand même c'est quand même c'est
quand même embêtant
donc je serais tenté de faire ça
pour géant a pas l'air de servir à grand
chose finalement un tour j'ai un tour G8
et c'est vrai qu'on c'est assez solide
pour les noirs
on va voir on va voir ce qu'il fait et
deux de 30 contre 2 minutes bon après ça
a des tendances très anulante on enlève
les dames c'est nul parce que les
finales de Tours vont jamais gagner avec
un nombre de pions égales même si on
sacrifie un pion souvent fait nul dans
le genre de course là c'est souvent nul
mais on va voir ton projet 7 ne marche
pas je ne crois pas mon cher Antoine ton
géant rouage c'est Dame F6 dont j'ai 8
et nada
alors peut-être
j'ai l'impression que
a perdu
on va regarder ouais c'est perdu pour
les caronakamura
qui est le premier à l'emporter
magnifique Magnus sans grande forme qui
confirme sa grande forme F6 vient d'être
joué G6 alors là on peut faire le coup
du le coup du visa
tour des trois menace d'un principe
ça va être très fort coup tout
simplement parce que c'est pas facile à
empêcher tout ça
et c'est jouer tour des trois et dame 5
c'était prévu par Maxime bachelagrave
sur d'un point H6 on apprend H6 ton H3
et on interpose la dame par damage 5
et tout va bien
donc maintenant il y a tout rage 3 qui
est un coup
c'est très chaud c'est très très chaud
ah on n'a pas de main donc on va faire
H5 on va être obligé
tourger 5 menaces tout en finesse on
prend un H5 dame 2 certainement
et attention ce pâté de pièces alors
c'est très beau c'est en maths mais si
on met pas ça reste un pâté de pièces
qui s'occupe pas du tout de suite
ça peut tourner c'est vraiment une
partie à trois résultats
clairement
ouais contre manus aussi en forme c'est
compliqué pour tout le monde clairement
aucune chance c'est un peu
non allez du fil à retordre sur le
dernier champions chasse tour à Magnus
il a perdu le premier match mais le
deuxième match il y a deux partout il a
gagné une partie il y a eu l'Armageddon
c'était chaud allez les indices il faut
jouer mon petit allié resa ton G5 jouer
d'un E2
tu fais quoi où et d'un F4 et les noirs
sont mieux je vous l'avais dit c'était
trois résultats cette histoire
4 secondes c'est en rappel la cadence
qui est de 15 + 3
donc attention
à
toi mon cher Ali resa parce que là
à force de jouer avec le feu
mais alors comment on est mieux avec les
Noirs j'en sais rien franchement c'est
trop c'est encore trop compliqué puis on
prend un trois tout simplement
est-ce qu'on
non je crois pas
et si on menace on prend H5 certainement
non c'est pas celle-là pardon pardon
pardon autant pour moi ou pas ça
malheureusement
j'ai 7 aussi donc ça ne va pas donc
attention d'un F4 c'est vrai que ça a
l'air fort ça menace on reprend H5
comment on fait pour le parer et bien
comme ça
non
parce que tu reprends ça change 8 alors
ok j'ai compris
quand j'ai 8
peut-être le bon coup
ah mais attendez si je bête
et c'est pour ça que les noirs sont
mieux
alors qu'est-ce qui a été joué dans tes
jouets évidemment
quoi
il veut garder les tours ouh là là ça
craint qui prend tous les risques là
mais attention il se fait contrer il est
en train de se faire contrer la part mvl
on va voir
et ces quatre ouh c'est pas mal joué ça
tourgé trois qui est une gaffe ouais on
va enfin ralenti sur ça B3 puis on prend
puis on prend faut jouera bien sûr c'est
mettre du couloir Damien
attention master 3 h 5 aussi on va se
mettre en 3 avec les Blancs donc faut
faire attention des deux côtés d'un
oreille Adam C1 mais peut-être on peut
prendre et jouer le tour C8 je sais pas
ce qu'il faut faire ici en tout cas il
faut faire quelque chose contre tu
reprends H5 ça c'est sûr
Maxime qui réfléchit dame jouer damséen
peut-être la finale de tour aller mieux
pour les Noirs quand même avec tour B6
qui peut ramasser le le pion maintenant
il dit finalement ok mais dans mes
conditions là il va être obligé de jouer
tourger ou un truc un truc qu'on a pas
envie de faire tour C3 ça ne va pas
selon la jauge mais attention là ça se
joue sur les qualités de blitzer
et peut-être tourner 8 là pour menacer
tourner un à l'heure intéressant
c'est chaud bouillant ça jamais été
aussi chaud très second pour mvl
13 secondes quoi un
etours C8 on prend deux fois il y a
demain en maths attention il revêt pour
le match du couloir mais là il a raté
son attaque à Irisa il est foutu tout
simplement c'est la contre-attaque de
Maxime qui normalement devrait importer
3 garde un œil sur ça tourgé 3 ça perd
normalement tout reprend
qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer tout reprendre
je suppose quoi d'autre papillon ouh il
joue plus on prend waouh ça c'est une
surprise
la meuf de menace maths si Dame B2 il y
a Tourer c'est fini Maxime machin grave
qu'il a emporté on va faire le ralenti
là parce que c'était passionnant
cette fin de partie était quand même
attente et on voit H5 jouer par Maxime
tour G5 dames 2 là il fallait prendre la
nulle comme ça tout reprend H5 comment
il fallait faire et damger 5 prenez la
nul parce qu'on menace ça et ça et du
coup les noirs sont obligés de faire de
ma fin de MC4 et prendre la nul et à
partir de là c'est foutu
B3 C4 qui était une gaffe apparemment il
fait jouer tour aux trois qui a été joué
non tour G3 a été joué Torro 3
pourquoi c'était meilleur puis on prend
puis on prend Robin
c'est dur à dire quand même Dame des 7
et 93
mais Irisa il est revenu ici qui
menaçait maths et qui avait l'air très
bien mais il y a de la mort et pour huit
et là c'est terminé trop faible
pour ces trois et Tours C8 super bien
joué si on prend deux fois c'est mettre
du couloir
tout simplement
donc on peut pas mais la l'initiative
est vraiment pour les Noirs Dame des
quatre encore une tactique qui joue sur
la tour ici monastère
pourquoi il a pas pris en fait il aurait
voulu prendre de la tour évidemment il y
a des F2
et c'est complètement terminé surtout
des trois on fait tout simplement tour
de voyez la différence entre les deux
rois c'est clairement ça et ce pion là
qui est très fort on peut jamais prendre
B3 il y a tout Rouen qui parle la dame
et les blancs sont complètement
paralysés on va peut-être faire tourner
de faire des choses pour s'amuser mais
c'est fini
puis on prend ces trois dam F2 menace et
menace Tourer
le notre jeune ami resa a abandonné on
va mettre deux points
pour
notre ami Maxime et Ali Resort à la
lourde tâche
de devoir d'être dans l'obligation de
gagner avec les noirs pour recoller au
score mais c'est possible on en a vu
d'autres on va regarder le bracket pour
voir ce qui s'est passé dans les autres
matchs et on voit car scène n'est pas
mis à chi ouais n'est pas bien chic a
été très impressionnant aujourd'hui
d'une misère et demi
deux pour Maxime achètes à sa fille
rouge à une petite nulle assez gagnée
et
en face on a lasavie contre ma média
Rohff
ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va faire une petite pub
Maxime aura les blancs dans la prochaine
on va faire une petite pub parce qu'on
doit la faire je sais pas dans combien
de temps ils reprennent mais non il a il
a bloqué sa caméra je vais essayer
d'aller voir si j'ai un faux là mais en
tout cas c'est bientôt cinq petites
minutes de pub et on revient merci de me
suivre tout de suite pour cette dernière
partie entre Maxime achat grave et allez
ça
fait rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour pour
cette dernière partie du match entre
Maxime vacheragrave et les résa firoga
Maxime qui mène 2 à 1 qui a gagné une
partie dans son style Une naydorf ou
vraiment il l'a pris en compte à lireza
les raisins qui a cherché
chercher davantage alors que finalement
maxime a très bien défendu s'est mis mal
au temps et benaboum la contre-attaque
mvl in voilà bravo à lui
donc Maxime aura les blancs en plus dans
la dernière face à l'IRESA et donc il
aura besoin d'une nul pour gagner ce
match tandis que
dans les autres matchs on a et bien
manus Carlsen qui a battu et
carunakamura on aura un Carson nepo
demain très très sympa
et dans looser bracket on a la caméra
guéri et donc on aura soit Maxime soit
fille rouge
qui
qui vont devoir
et bien il y en a un qui passera en
demi-finale des gagnants face à lasavik
ou ma média Rohff et un qui passera de
finale des perdants
voilà voilà pour la petite histoire
de
[Musique]
de ce tournoi on va montrer le trophée
qui est magnifique alors est-ce que
c'est de la NFT ou pas je crois pas
mais je sais pas honnêtement
je sais pas
là honnêtement
j'en sais rien
j'ai demandé à une question pour Nathan
maintenant si tu es là tu nous écoutes
Nathan n'hésite pas à nous dire si c'est
NFC ou pas
bon bref peu importe en tout cas il y a
des gros prix dans ces tournois 150 000
dollars à chaque tournoi et encore plus
des bonus et tout ça donc il y a je
crois que c'est un million de dollars de
prix en tout donc c'est quand même c'est
assez énorme
alors
on va revenir sur
quoi et je vais répondre à vos questions
on va montrer et on voit Maxime qui
s'installe d'abord
on va regarder le truc NFT ou là
aquality c'est pas terrible alors la
réponse je cherche console beaucoup
recommandations pour la carroscan
cependant je la trouve très Peugeot au
niveau c'est vrai qu'elle est assez peu
joué bon
faut mettre de mode mais ça tient très
bien la carrocane il y a aucun problème
vous savez que c'est moins joué il y a
un petit il y a un petit boom autour de
la française en ce moment
évidemment les E40
et et
les siciliennes restent les
les favoris des tops joueurs mais voilà
la kaokane va et vient ça reste une
ouverture quand même très très solide
mieux vaut les pépettes
alors je sais pas si un t-shirt nage
d'or de mvl ouais je joue à l'âge d'or
et je m'appelle mvl on peut faire un
t-shirt toi effectivement
ouais donc je sais pas si c'est de la
NFT ou pas
en tout cas on va voir les joueurs
revenir
et on va évidemment regarder la partie
dès qu'elle commence je pense que alien
Maxime vont pas tarder ouais on les voit
dans
deux petites minutes je pense
non allez repart avec une jolie plante
une jolie plante quand même à les
raisins
dans son fond
et on voit de 1
pour Maxime qui se concentre
très concentré aujourd'hui Maxime ça
il a il a décidé de prendre ses tournois
online beaucoup plus au sérieux
on le voit là dans son attitude
clairement
on va voir
ce que ça donne
ça c'est pas bon
et on va tout de suite vous mettre la
partie
dès qu'elle commence
et une victoire de prestige quand même
contre les offres pas de mal clairement
réglé blanc bon bah il va jouer il va
jouer 4 hein certainement et
je sais pas de la part de Ali hasard qui
peut pas se permettre de jouer une
pétrole dans cette partie évidemment
il le sait très bien à les raisins il va
pas jouer de pétrole et on a la
quatrième partie qui va reprendre
sous nos yeux
on va
voir la mettre ici aussi
et revenir voilà la qualité de l'air
chez manuscrit en pas terrible
maintenant
et ça va commencer
ça va commencer pour Maxime qui va jouer
franchement je serais très surpris si je
jouais pas au 4 il a besoin d'une nulle
c'est Ali resa de faire le jeu
clairement
15 + 3 on le rappelle au meilleur des
quatre parties et donc on a cette
quatrième partie si elle est à gagne ça
sera un Armageddon mais il faut d'abord
passer la montagne mvl avec les noirs
ça peut être facile et voilà car au cas
on va parler ah génial génial voilà car
aucun c'est pour gagner
et c'est trois la ligne la plus solide
alors est-ce qu'on va avoir droit à ce
pion prank cavalier prend et cavalier F6
certainement mais c'est pas sûr
peut-être qu'elle ira considérer que
c'est trop solide et va jouer un coup
comme G6
comme A6
mais a priori puis on prend que les
pranks6 va venir
c'est un signe oui tout à fait
certainement
alors
comment il va faire
non c'est non la quarantaine ça peut
jouer alors ouais le problème de ces
lignes là c'est ça c'est extrêmement
solide pour les blancs et pour les noirs
et des 7 c'est extrêmement c'est trop
solide aussi donc il va pas jouer ça
si je joue ça il me fait mentir voilà ok
bon pour moi alors
qu'est-ce que je vous dise et ta F3
jouer par Maxime ok alors là une petite
souligne alors que j'ai trois est
tellement solide pour les blancs ok
décidément les deux joueurs qui me
surprennent
je ne devine aucun coup
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire à lire
Elsa est-ce qu'on prend ici ou est-ce
qu'on joue 6
moi je vois pas ce qu'il y a de mal avec
fuj6 mais c'est clair que Maxime connaît
il y a aucun doute sur ça
il faut G6 ok le coup de Maxime va
arriver très vite parce que foget 6 est
quand même le coup évident c'est trois
on protège le pion
mais je trouve que ce coup de Dam F3
franchement c'est un peu bizarre quand
on a besoin de faire nul
pourquoi pas pour l'instant il a il a
démontré depuis le début de ce match qui
sait très bien ce qu'il fait dans ce
match clairement
il a été très bon cahier des 7 c'est
normal pour jouer tranquillement calife
6 ou peut-être 5 qui peut être aussi un
coup un coup intéressant
on va voir ce que va faire Maxime
prend H4 c'est un peu à l'abordage mais
bon là ça serait vu les circonstances ça
serait quand même assez étrange foutez
trois cavaliers de aussi une option
cavalier H3 cavalier F4 énormément de
plan ici commence à réfléchir c'est un
peu étrange mais bon
pourquoi pas
début réussi de la part de les raisins
du coup s'il fait réfléchir un maximum
aussitôt dans une position quand même ou
il reste beaucoup de pièces alors ça
reste évidemment la structure archi
solide pour les blancs les blancs sont
pour moins bien ça c'est évident mais
quand même c'est quatre qui d'après la
jauge et une petite précision alors
attention
de pas trop se vierge évidemment faut
prendre un 4 mains on est plus possible
à cause d'un prime cette mat mais ça il
y a pas de problème c'est que ça empêche
plus ou moins 5 c'est vrai que 5 ça
serait
comme embêtant le jeu 5 en se fout
rayonne comme ça sur le sur le pur F7 kg
d'abord par exemple qui avait les deux
on se développe surpuis on prend puis on
prend on va jouer rock
on est quand même bien donc fous ces
quatre à mon avis va le coût correct
c'est cavalier F6 à peu près certain
mais il y a les circonstances du match
qui font que effectivement
envie de complexifier un petit peu plus
la position
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire notre
animaxime
évidemment on est là tous les jours
jusqu'à vendredi tous les jours 18
heures
mais pour être sûr parce que parfois je
sais pas si loser bracket va pas
commencer plus tôt en fait
ça je suis pas complètement sûr
donc de toute façon on suit les Français
ça c'est sûr donc si loser market
commence à 17h abonnez-vous à nos
réseaux sociaux chez com Instagram
Twitter x pardon Facebook
tout ce que vous voulez les chaînes
évidemment
les chaînes YouTube donc n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner comme ça vous ratez pas et
vous ratez pas le début des parties et
au 5 jouets quand même le cinquième
avait l'air un peu douteux mais bon il
faut faire quelque chose de particulier
pour l'emporter face à Maxime Vacher la
grave avec les noirs
dame de ouais un piège un piège bien
connu
j'avais placé ton enfant
quand j'étais jeune à la coupe
la coupe moins de 17 ans
la coupe Jean-Claude Loubatiere
ça fait Coupe de la Fédération à
l'époque et qui a pris le nom de son
inventeur Jean-Claude ou bah tiens
j'avais placé et mon adversaire est pas
aller chercher
vous comprenez pas très bien ce qui se
passait
puis on prend puis on prend qu'est-ce
qu'il veut faire échec certainement
et c'est vrai qu'on a créé un
déséquilibre en l'occurrence ce pion
passé
oui les couleurs sont bonnes il y a deux
un pour Maxime tout est bon
va certainement arriver et surtout des
deux on fait prendre des deux
et si on prend du cavalier tout
simplement que le F6 maintenant on va ok
au prochain coup et tout va bien pour
les noirs et on a même une cible
si on prend du roi c'est quand même très
osé de prendre du rond mais bon
peut-être peut-être que c'est le mieux
non c'est pas bon du tout qu'est-ce
qu'il y a encore une pièce
ou il y a cavalier 5 il fait très mal
et on voit ce vis-à-vis donc ça serait
pas bon du tout
je pense que ça va être joué par les
hasard évidemment Maxime va pas tomber
dans genre de pièce de piège de pièces
de pièges voilà
fou B 4 c'est quoi c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
embête j'arrive pas à savoir
et c'est trois se met dans le clouage
donc ça va jamais très bon ce genre de
coup peut-être que c'est 3
que les 6
très confort pour les Noirs bon après ce
que c'est assez pour être vraiment mieux
peut-être déjà
et c'est quoi ces autres options aliasa
je les vois pas cavalier
quatre échecs évidemment il met beaucoup
de temps il est un peu lent dans ce
début de
dans ce début de partie
et cavalier 4c3 parce qu'il y en aveu
d'échec maintenant on peut faire
cavalier F6 et rock et on a un pion
isolé on est très content du début de
partie avec les noirs
parce que on a obtenu une position
déséquilibrée avec ce pion isolé on peut
pas s'en débarrasser il y aura toujours
cavalier au 5
donc c'est quand même pas évident pour
les blancs
et ça reste une position déséquilibrée
c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait avec
les noirs
alors maintenant comment on joue avec
les Blancs il y a plein de pièces en
plus bon ça c'est censé favoriser quand
même le joueur qui a le pion isolé
d'avoir plein de pièces mais bon ça joue
ce fou est très bien placé en G6 il
pourra aller bondir ici parfois qui est
B6 va arriver on a une bonne bloca dans
des cinq ça parait quand même très très
raisonnable pour les pour les noirs
comment on fait ici je sais pas
peut-être que
quand on sait pas quoi faire enclos
c'est un logique après on peut on peut
se découvrir un coup en attaquant le fou
ça a l'air ça a l'air pas mal
donc
petit rock
et Maxime qui prend sa première pause
sa petite réflexion
ici je suis assez curieux de voir son
couple peut-être fou B3 pour empêcher
que KBC soit sur tempo
ça me semble aussi assez raisonnable
beaucoup de coupes aussi
n'importe quel coup de développement et
aussi un coup normal
les trois j'aime bien parce qu'on attend
de voir comment les Noirs se développent
alors
Maxime qui a réfléchit et qui rattrape
un petit peu les raisins
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il se regarde
les deux joueurs
ils aiment bien on aime bien voir quand
on peut il faut B3 jouer par Maxime
voilà très logique d'attendre un petit
peu pour voir par exemple sur kb6 voyez
fouger 5 aurait beaucoup plus de force
maintenant parce qu'en gros
donc c'est pour ça que c'est un coup
utile
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici pour 8
j'aime pas trop parce qu'après cavalier
F4 on peut avoir des problèmes sur F7
je sais pas parce que j'aurai ici avec
les doigts c'est pas facile
honnêtement elle est pas facile cette
position
Damas quand même ok empêche 5
latéralement Lille et tours on va
certainement mettre une toux ici ça a
beaucoup de sens ça avait encore plus
évidemment quand le fou était en G5 mais
même maintenant ça a du sens
et maintenant que font les blancs
on sait pas quoi faire des deux côtés
clairement on va pas monter d'attaque
avec les Blancs donc faut essayer de se
débarrasser de ce pion en fait c'est ça
la c'est ça la question peut-être à
trois
ok ça c'est logique il veut il veut
prendre ce foodcast blanche OK
ok les deux joueurs qui arrivent à
faire des coups quand même très logique
et maintenant la balle est dans le camp
de notre ami à
est-ce qu'on a envie de donner ce fou
première question je crois que non la
réponse est non
est-ce qu'il y en a un moyen de pas le
donner
je crois que la réponse est non encore
par exemple ça
ce que je peux pas faire ça maintenant
aussi
parce que si on perd ce fou ça va être
compliqué d'avoir un avantage
honnêtement
ça va être très très complexe
finalement est-ce qu'il a aussi bien je
me suis un peu enflammé peut-être en
disant que les résa avait réussi son
ouverture
je suis plus sûr honnêtement
parce que non seulement pas facile à
jouer
3 minutes de moins
et avec les Blancs ouais on a un jeu
quand même assez simple
il faut F5 jouets
H3 Maxime à tempo et oui pas
d'embrouille avec fougères peut-être un
G4 qui menace
tout à fait intéressant ce qui fait
est-ce que la zavik est
ma média font appel à un que les deux le
vainqueur jouera le vainqueur de ce
match et le père d'un jour rencontre le
perdant de ce match il y a eu quatrième
nul entre ma media off et la zavie qu'on
aura un armage et donc on va suivre de
toute façon
une fois que ça commence
mais bon pour l'instant évidemment on
reste sur nos sur nos français pour voir
contre qui joue
mon tableau pour maxi vous pourra lire
ça et oui oui parce que quand on joue
pas Manu scarlsen quand on animal
dans son tableau avant la finale en tout
cas et bien c'est un bon tableau ça
c'est évident
alors H3 est-ce qu'on peut il fait tout
re 8 ok j'avais proposé H6 pour faire
une case au fou mais il propose de faire
tourner 8 donc là il a complètement
enlevé la protection du pion F7
bon ben ce qui est plutôt courageux
parce que c'est pas sûr du tout que ça
soit vraiment
qui est pas une embrouille qui arrive
mais bon il a confiance à son calcul
est-ce que un coup comme ça et par
exemple est pas possible
voyez on fait on attaque ici
au pire on ferait ça
ça me prend avec 6 et tout va bien pour
les Noirs ça c'est une certitude
donc voilà la confiance en son calcul
une fois de plus à les raisins et puis
toute façon il doit prendre tous les
risques dans cette partie donc pourquoi
pas quelque chose d'acrobatique pour A8
c'est vrai
c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que fu F5 H3
tour A8 était aussi un coup
qui gardait la protection de spion mais
c'est vrai que naturellement on a envie
de mettre cette tour en D8 et
finalement si on n'a pas peur de fantôme
à F7 alors évidemment les gens normaux
comme nous ont peur des fantômes
mais pas ce genre de joueur
donc pour 8 pour garder la meilleure
case
pour la tour en D8 alors
on va voir
maintenant
et j'ai quatre jouets par
Maxime va chier La Grave et qui joue pas
il a trop d'expérience pour jouer la
petite nul il joue les coups qui lui
semblent mieux et au moment de répéter
les coups si il y a une répétition
évidemment qu'il le fera mais pour
l'instant il joue normalement il joue
son jeu Maxime pourquoi déjouer quand on
joue aussi bien quand on joue aussi bien
depuis ces quelques derniers mois là de
la part de Maxime
au mois dernière semaine en tout cas où
il y a clairement élevé son niveau de
jeu
donc Maxime là qui va
qui va clairement G4 il veut clairement
prendre ce fou de casse blanche
et
poser des questions à lire raison
ou je ne prince à les raisins qui est
encore peut-être quelques leçons à
apprendre de Maxime et oui aussi il faut
pas faut pas l'oublier
et comment on fait sur G4
pas évident parce que il y a ce pion
vous voyez par exemple où G6 on prend je
prends et hop et hop là
ça va pas du tout
pour les noirs
donc j'ai 4 x 4 jouets qui prend le 4 et
maintenant de quoi on reprend alors
attention attention
il y a pas G5 parce que la dame tient
chromatique cette histoire de la part
d'aller résa qui joue un petit peu avec
le feu
qui chauffe clairement Maxime et qu'elle
prend un cadre comment on fait avec des
blancs
je suis pas sûr excusez-moi
alors que c'est chaud que c'est chaud
cette histoire
alors là il a un gros choix à lire il
faut que je joue un peu plus vite allez
vas y avoir des chances 5 minutes contre
9-40 on a vu
dans la deuxième il était mal au temps
et seul dans la troisième pardon et
celle-là je vais quand même
des tours
alors question qui est nouvelle un frère
de Maxime Laurent Blanc on le sait
depuis tout à ta style quand même
franchement
Albin Lagaffe salut Laurent tu trouves
pas que le niveau chez amateur
s'améliore cette année oui oui donc
clairement mal à la source elle estime
les vidéos
le fait d'avoir stock fish à la maison à
n'importe quel moment que en fait le
savoir
le savoir c'est quand même accessible
beaucoup plus facilement le savoir est
accessible en un clic
donc effectivement évidemment que le
niveau c'est
énormément progressé
c'est aussi le fait que les jeunes
joueurs atteignent le plafond de verre
peut-être plutôt on verra mais voyez
elle est Raisa elle a eu 2800 à 18 ans
est-ce qu'il aura plus
ça devient de moins en moins sûr
est-ce qu'il a pas eu son meilleur vélo
à 18 ans finalement
on va voir
alors tour à 8
et
bah là c'est logique du coup
tour des un coup un coup assez mou qui
protège le pion certes mais qui menace
rien et en joues pour 8 on met les tours
comme ça voilà faut trois coups de
développement il faut se développer
et en menace des 5 je pense des 5 pour
finalement ouvrir la paire de fou et
essayer d'en faire quelque chose
et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait après faut
et bien j'en sais rien
peut-être qu'il B6 pour empêcher des
seins quoi que j'ai envie de garder ce
cavalier là pour qu'il puisse venir ça
quoi il fait fouder si c'est oui le Food
n'avait plus rien à faire en B4 il taper
dans taper dans le vide donc faut des 6
très très intelligent bien jouer de la
part de la RSA
menace peut-être du fuprint F4 peut-être
pas tout de suite mais ça peut venir et
comment on fait avec les Blancs ici
mais c'est pas évident
pas évident du tout là pour pour Maxime
alors attention
ce G4 va peut-être être regretté en tout
cas c'est une très belle partie et c'est
exactement ce dont avait besoin les
raisins dans cette dernière partie
une partie à double tranchant
je pense qu'on va voir les jeunes
Indiens là on va on va avoir beaucoup
alors pas tout ça évidemment mais
on va avoir beaucoup qui vont atteindre
leur niveau maximum et alors hello
maximum beaucoup plus tôt qu'avant avant
c'était 25-30 ans
maintenant je pense que ça va être plus
jeune voilà
c'est mon
mon sentiment parce que
[Musique]
ça dur de progresser un moment c'est ça
un certain niveau progressé devient très
très difficile et oui déjà tous les
niveaux c'est difficile alors imaginez
bien que
k2800 c'est extrêmement compliqué
et comment il fait maximilient pas bien
Maxime et pas facile à jouer cette
position dès qu'on le cavalier vas-y que
je t'installe un truc là et attention
attention et puis attention c'est du
gruyère là-bas on peut quand même ça
peut mal se terminer ces histoires
toi c'est un jouet par Maxime ok ok
normal un coup normal
pas trop ce que ça menace mais bon ça
sort la tour éventuellement ça peut
s'ouvrir un jour grâce à des cinq
mais
clairement intéressant
on voit maintenant à 9 ans ils font des
normes de mi là vous avez vu le jeune
ça paraît dingue ça pourrait pas arriver
avant et je pense pas qu'il est plus de
talent que Kasparov ce jeune homme
casse pas de normes de mi à 9 ans voilà
donc on voit qu'il y a une accélération
on a progression clairement après
peut-être que c'est nouveau peut-être
que ça va être un mélange de kasparo
Fischer et Carlson on sait pas mais bon
ça paraît
[Musique]
ça paraît pas pas probable est-ce qu'il
a été un peu aidé pour la norme ah ben
j'en sais rien ça j'ai pas su j'ai vu
juste l'info
alors là
j'en ai aucune idée
nouvelle façon de jouer aussi
effectivement beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus concrète peut-être qu'ils
comprennent mieux le jeu si c'est ça
alors kb6 pour faire cahier des 5
et installer quelque chose de
beaucoup plus ami quoi plus que statique
oui tout à fait tout à fait non c'est
sûr ça ça joue différemment donc et B6
coûte très logique même si la jauge
n'aime pas
enfin elle n'aime pas elle remet égal ou
de mettre un léger avantage pour les
noirs
alors qui est B6 pour faire cahier des 5
mais
on va voir ce qui m'inquiète chez alias
c'est simplement 3 minutes alors il est
très rapide certes mais c'est du 15 + 3
donc c'est 3 secondes c'est un matelas
très fragile à ces trois secondes et
bien sûr qu'on est plus efficace partout
les joueurs se défendent beaucoup mieux
on s'est aperçu que quand même on
pouvait défendre on pouvait défendre
quand même
[Musique]
beaucoup beaucoup de positions fallait
en faire beaucoup
pour perdre une partie d'échec
d'accord des nuls faciles accordées par
des GM après il a du talent et
indéniable ouais d'accord on verra de
toute façon c'est pas après ouais non
c'est toujours
c'est clairement une aide
ces trucs de faire d'avoir une
exposition très jeune parce que ça
permet d'avoir des invitations et de
jouer contre de très forts joueurs très
jeune
donc ça c'est évidemment bénéfique pour
le développement du joueur
c'est par exemple les jeunes joueurs
prodige j'en vois Peter LEGO à l'époque
il était prodige il était invité à
l'inarès évidemment il s'est développé
très très jeune il est devenu très fort
très jeune parce qu'il a eu beaucoup
d'invitations je dis de Paul gars en
plus non seulement elle était très forte
mais en plus c'était une femme ce qui
change évidemment
des habitudes où on voyait envoyer dans
les Torah du top d'ailleurs maintenant
aussi on voit quasiment exclusivement
que des hommes
et donc cet attrait là aussi et donc ça
lui a permis d'avoir énormément
d'invitations
et donc de jouer les meilleurs joueurs
du monde et donc évidemment quand on
joue avec les meilleurs et bien on
développe son jeu beaucoup plus
rapidement
donc c'est un gros avantage de d'avoir
des résultats jeunes parce que ça permet
d'avoir des invitations et de jouer les
meilleurs joueurs du monde et donc de se
développer beaucoup beaucoup plus vite
d'apprendre des choses au contact des
meilleurs beaucoup plus rapidement
et cavalier ok donc c'était pour faire
quai G5 mais on a eu H4 mais c'est vrai
qu'elle savait vraiment c'était
pas facile pour lui et il a eu tout le
mérite le mérite lui revient bien
évidemment
et il donne de fou et bien dis donc et
il veut mettre évidemment installer un
autre cavalier ici en dessin qui a deux
très beaux cavaliers qu'on sait très
intéressant je vois très vite vous
prendre F4
ouais non bien sûr je dis tu as été
classé dans le top 10 mondial mixte donc
c'était
largement légitime ses invitations
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit je
dis qu'elle en a eu un peu plus qu'un
joueur de son niveau en étant joueuse
mais ce qui est normal ça crame après
supplémentaire c'est comme ça
Magnus car scène avait une bouille pas
possible quand il était jeune il est
beaucoup d'invitations non seulement
parce que il y avait un talent
incroyable mais au même niveau il y
avait des joueurs qui est moins
d'invitations parce que Manu s'est
exprimait bien en anglais il avait quand
même une bouille assez incroyable ça
joue aussi les organisateurs ils font ce
qu'ils veulent ils sont ils sont
évidemment
mettre en leur royaume
j'ai dit tu as été numéro 7 d'accord
ah non mais il a beaucoup de talents
bien sûr qu'il a un don par rapport aux
autres
je dis pas que Magnus a pas travaillé
mais évidemment qu'il a un don moi qui
travaille avec lui je peux vous dire
qu'il a un don
il a une super mémoire il a une super
belle intuition pour le jeu
c'était moche c'est pas invité ben moi
si tu vaut mieux être charismatique les
organisateurs préfèrent les joueurs
charismatiques c'est sûr
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que
Karekin par exemple était pas moins fort
que Magnus
mais il y a moins d'invitation voilà
quand il était jeune par exemple
il y a bien une raison
je pense que la gueule joue le charisme
général charisme c'est
alors
tour C2 jouer par mvl on
c'est un peu perdu le style de jeu aussi
évidemment regardez Maxime il avait il a
aussi beaucoup d'invitations mais c'est
mérité mais il a un style de jeu que les
gens ont envie de voir c'est nager on
fait tout ça donc ça c'est sympa les
raisins aussi ce bol jusqu'au dernier
pion
ça aussi c'est tout un ensemble qui
permet d'avoir plus d'invitations c'est
évident
tour ces deux jouets et
pour faire pour certainement contester
cette colonne et c'est doublé par là bon
43 secondes pour aller Raisa alors ici
effectivement il a une belle position
mais ça reste il faut quand même encore
faire la différence ça peut être évident
mais
on va voir qui est une gaffe d'après la
jauge pourquoi je n'ai pas compris ce
coup qu'est-ce qui se passe sur tour de
on ne sait pas il est bien Maxime tour 2
c'est peut-être non ok j'ai 5 j'ai juste
fou prendre ça va pas être bon ça ça va
pas être bon au minimum j'ai ça faut
prendre F7 il faut prendre 8 et c'est
terminé
au minimum donc sur ces deux kb4 et
tours de jouer
par Maxime
j'aime pas du tout ce qu'il fait à lire
les accueil dessin qui revient
évidemment qui va pas revenir en C2 il
est évidemment qu'il est d'accord avec
la lune mais tour C2 est pas du tout un
bon coup dans cette position donc il va
faire autre chose mvl c'est une évidence
il va certainement doubler ici si c'est
possible
je vois pas de contre-indication pour
être honnête
Tourer coûte tellement logique et c'est
dommage pour y aller ça parce qu'il a
une belle position il va pas répéter les
coups ici Maxime faut 5 aussi envisager
parce que ce cavalier se retrouve bien
seul
alors
maintenant
comment il va faire il réfléchit Maxime
il a bien raison il y a 3 minutes contre
25 secondes
et il a envie d'en terminer maintenant
c'est évident
et pour
attaque 4
et comment on fait maintenant la peau
d'Ali resa voilà il doit battre en
retraite mais il est moins bien là c'est
sûr il a peur de fou il a complètement
perdu le fil notre jeune ami Ali resa on
y va encaisser il va jouer le foot 5 ou
quelque chose comme ça Maxime
il est en contrôle totalement chez
agrave là
il prend sa voix un peu terrible mais il
fait cavaler prend quand même
d'être attention à la tour oula j'ai
proposé un cookie donné à tour
peut-être tour 5 d'abord alors
5 jouets et dame débutant se replie et
il fait quoi sur le clouage maxi
il est pas bien après la jauge et ça
ressemble à quand même
quasi qualifle mais bon attention
attention il peut y avoir des
retournements dans la dernière seconde
on connaît
on connaît ce genre de choses et fouger
5 pour le clouage de toute façon on
reste l'armée Guédon et entre la zavie
qui est ma médias Rohff qui déterminera
l'adversaire des deux joueurs dès demain
à ne pas rater à partir de 18h mardi
tous les jours à partir de 18h ou la
dame prend des cartes c'est une gaffe
puis on prend qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
la dame prend et sur dame prend G4 on
peut simplement partir avec le roi ça a
l'air complètement gagnant
ça a l'air fini il va y avoir tourgé ça
qui va arriver il y a le pion F7 aussi
qui traîne
c'est un désastre pour le jeune
Prince Ali resa là qui est dans le dur
et on le voit même physiquement il est
dans le dur
j'ai l'impression que ça gagne ça tout
simplement et sur MG7 on va faire tout
j'ai 5 ou pas pas sûr qu'on fasse
tourger 5 parce que j'ai 5 heures ok
j'ai 6 peut-être ça sera ça l'embrouille
attention
sur H5 on a ref-6
faut faire très attention dames prends
un si ça a été joué d'un projet 4 a été
joué mais la Maximy va faire mieux que
moi peut-être roche 2
mesdames j'ai 7 va venir c'est sûr la G7
et le prochain coup d'aller les raisins
il a pris move dame G7 moi je vous le
dis
parce qu'il a pas le choix c'est parce
que
ça fait trop donc ça va pas aller
donc attention attention notre ami à les
hasard ouais faut madame G7 c'était
PRIMOVE annoncé par la patrouille et on
garde le clouage mais que c'est bien
joué dans ma fuite ouh là là là là ça
s'est pas terrible ça ça se termine mal
ce genre de choses Dame des 7 par
exemple et bien ça paralyse la petite
famille
encore j'en sais rien peut-être pour G5
a une pièce aussi ah non tous les cinq
et j'ai 6 pardon autant pour moi dame
prend on apprend à se déclos H5 c'est
une gaffe d'après la jauge Kai G6 non ok
J6 marche pas pourquoi c'est une gaffe
cahier des 5 non tour G5 pourquoi c'est
une gaffe
ouais je suis qui perd tout de suite
apparemment mais c'était que c'était dur
je sais pas quel était le coup je
mettrai la jauge après pour voir quel
était le coup mais j'en ai aucune idée
comment on finisse ce travail d'un
mecisse d'un problème c'est à l'heure
d'être assez peut-être H6 aussi pas mal
ou quelle histoire pour aller raisin
attention 34 secondes quand même pour
Maxime
il faut faire attention Maxime joue un
peu plus vite
alors qu'est-ce qui va jouer il
réfléchit comment terminer le travail et
s'ils sont durs à battre ces joueurs là
moi je vous le dis j'ai cette dame prend
F7
et ouais c'est ça dame prend 5 et roi G7
obligé
et où j'ai de prendre le 5 ouais d'un
pro et 3G7 et ça joue encore il est là
il est là allez les surdam et on reprend
à 5 ans attention
poussez de attaquage 7 bien joué encore
ah s'il a besoin de faire nul à l'IRESA
ça irait certainement mais là je crois
qu'il va être obligé de prendre le
perpète en fait il va faire dame G5 et
dame G7 peut-être et je proposais à
petite finale il a pas le choix menacer
maintenant H7 donc il y a pas le choix
de MCA oula
n'a pas été vu par la patrouille ça
enfin j'ai deux dames français de
maintenant
obligé ouais dame français
et attention maintenant on est là merci
de perpette encore roi pareil
c'est quand même compliqué mais Maxime
qui s'est mis dans les dans les soucis
on verra ça au ralenti ce qu'il a raté
mais c'était pas évident en tout cas moi
je voyais pas non plus
je sais pas si ça prouve quelque chose
ou là pourquoi il a donné
et parce que il espère attaquer ici et
ici il voulait pas donner à me prendre
des deux sans avoir de me prendre 7
alors maintenant potentiellement ça a
gagné final de pion mais alors il faut
se sortir des échecs avec le roi dame F7
on va faire 4 ah là il perd le pion a ça
c'est mauvais mais attention ça peut ça
peut ça peut ça peut parce que attention
il y a le pion passé c'est
ça peut ça peut être chaud ce genre de
choses
3D 5 et peut-être maintenant on va
pousser alors attention
et Maxime là 9 secondes contre 5
attention ça pousse et oui là faut pas
réfléchir faut pas réfléchir avec les
Noirs faut pousser alors peut-être
les échecs B5 dames D8 et il améliore
maintenant ses pions c'est très chaud
alors là je mets nul mais franchement
moi je serai archi inquiet ici
je serai archi inquiet parce que ce pion
c'est quand même très très bien protégé
il y a des nuls mais ça va pas être
évident
dam dam qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer de
remplacer la dame là et mal placé cette
dame et dans le dur la dame elle est
très mal placé et on pousse ok on va
faire quoi il est moins bien Maxime
attention
attention sur F6 C2 F7 dame G7 ah c'est
foutu oh là là c'est pas possible
qu'elle retourne en situation c'est
incroyable il est foutu mvl comment il
est foutu j'en sais rien dame G7 et dame
oh il va se faire mater avec les deux
dames voilà ça serait improbable il est
obligé de faire dames il fait de me
prendre après il peut plus faire dames
il doit faire dames il y a deux hommes
fâché qui c'est très chèques
et maintenant comment ces échecs comment
on fait je n'en sais rien
ouh là là ouh là là il fait mal il fait
mal cet échec il fait très mal comment
on fait pour mater là on fait que des
échecs clairement il a la finale de pi
on gagne c'est ça le problème
c'est que si on échange tout si on
échange toutes les dames à la fin on
prend à deux et on pousse le pion
oh là là c'est magnifique cette finale
avec deux dames
rois B2 mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
mais il est fou ou quoi il donne il
donne il donne les échecs
non j'ai jamais vu ça
il est parti
il a perdu
mais non
mais non ce n'est incroyable ce coup de
roi B2
je n'ai jamais vu ça
c'est pas possible
ralenti
ralenti obligatoire
ralenti parce que là là franchement
là franchement
donc ok bon ok très bien ce qui se passe
avant bon compliqué tout ça
mais alors là il est gagnant il est
gagnant clairement mvl il a très bien
joué
bref
on ferme le cercueil on est bien dame
fuite la Dame des 7 c'était le meilleur
coup donné par tactique frais quand même
et H5 gaffe il fallait jouer cahier des
5 ici
on échange du matériel okhs8
la meuf 6 dam G7 là il est complètement
gagnant mais un problème ça a été très
bien ou faiwe F4 alors ça c'est trop dur
en fait le bon coup c'était de revenir
même des 6 ouais
7 et maintenant ça devient également
ça devient égal on sait de finale de
dame qu'on a vu qui est plutôt bien joué
dès le début mais elle est plus facile à
jouer pour les Noirs un peu de réussite
et là F6 c'est la gaffe il fallait jouer
dame 5
comme ça sur ces deux on avait un mais
ça c'est coup d'ordures
cette fille elle change d'avis ok F6
c'est de la F4 3b1 F7 et c'est là
où c'est incroyable là c'est maintenant
quatre coups
avec dam Cg1
c'est rof-3 c'est Dame G2 maths
7 G2
c'est incroyable roi des trois DAMS
et si on fait d'un F2
il y a dame 4 rois des deux d'un mat
mais en vrai la F2 c'est jamais possible
parce qu'il y a dame prend
au pire c'est ce que je veux dire on
reprend et hop et on file et ça va pas
du tout
et donc
là ce qui se passe dame G1 complètement
gagnant évidemment bref 3 c'est
maintenant c'est maintenant
le cas de la semaine
je vous dis ça avec leur dire
j'ai toujours complètement gagnant Dame
des cinq toujours complètement gagnant
bref si c'est la roi B2 il voulait jouer
dame B2
impossible ça sera pas et là il joue roi
B2
qui quand même qui garde les échecs et
ça va gagner
ouais moi je pense que son idée c'est de
faire un petit escalier là
et voilà un truc comme ça
et ça va gagner bon mais bravo bravo
Maxime bravo Maxime évidemment
on va voir contre qui va jouer contre
qui va-t-il jouer est-ce que la zavik
m'avait dit en fait ce qu'on a des
nouvelles
est-ce qu'ils vont jouer mais moi ce que
je vous propose
ils vont jouer après ils vont jouer les
gars Maxime
ce que je vous propose
c'est une proposition
j'ai déjà joué je vais aller je vais
aller dans le zoom
et je vais voir si je peux choper les
joueurs ou pas
n'importe quoi on peut avoir
je vais épingler
bon je vais faire ça ah oui c'est pas
mal ça
OK et je vais faire afficher
non
et on va épingler aussi notre ami laser
et on a les deux joueurs bah c'est pas
mal ça donc score final
lasselix c'est un jeune joueur très fort
score final pour Maxime machinagrave ça
sera trois points il sera demain en
demi-finale face à
suspense suspense et si vous voulez
savoir et bien si vous voulez savoir
bien il faut regarder
il faut regarder
l'Armageddon le nécessaire un magazon et
oui et on voit là
on va mettre ça comme ça
quand même on est là il est nécessaire à
magédon on va voir on va rester une
petite demi-heure en plus ensemble on
est bien là quand même et comme ça on a
on a donc lasavik a l'air on sait pas on
va changer non mais ma média of
lasavique à suivre pourquoi et bien
parce que ça fait de partout et donc on
a un Armageddon c'est toujours sympa on
va découvrir ce jeune joueur lasavique
moi il m'a j'ai joué
il a pas mal joué
il a été costaud donc sur ce qu'on fait
c'est quand on va on va quand même on va
se regarder qui est l'adversaire de mvl
tout de suite après la petite
pub à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour cette
Armageddon qui décidera du vainqueur
du de l'adversaire de demain de Maxime
machin graff et Dali resafiruja donc le
gagnant jouera Maxime et le perdant
jouera à l'IRESA les bides donc comment
ça marche et donc 15 minutes pour les
blancs
on fait des enchères avec les noirs et
donc ce qui se passe c'est que la plus
petite enchère évidemment le moins de
temps gagne l'enchère et donc prend les
noirs et chaque rire va venir enfin
proposer 11 minutes 20 alors ça c'est ce
que je fais moi-même 12 minutes mais 11
11 et quelques 11 11 20
en général on perd quand on propose ce
genre de temps et là
ça n'a pas raté la zavik a proposé 10
minutes et donc la zavie qui aura donc
les pièces noir
face à
[Musique]
face à chaque fois d'eau là on va
essayer de voir de face quand même je
vais changer les noms aussi
mvl donc là c'est ma media off
OK et
ma média name
on va essayer de le rapatrier vers là
voilà
face à la zavie donc
qu'on va tout de suite
voilà la zavik et on va essayer de voir
le
dos de oula j'ai fait n'importe quoi
donc ça on va l'enlever
et ce qu'on va faire c'est que
masquer la vignette non
participants non
OK et on va
mettre notre ami
ma média off comme ça voilà ça va être
mieux ah la poisse
hop là on va le mettre là
et ma médiérophe il va il va
apparaître sous
gagner donc là il y a deux
et
de deux et donc il y a eu dans ce match
donc match très très serré
et
donc c'est le fameux Maguet donc 15
minutes qu'on dit obligation pour les
blancs de l'emporter et on va vibrer
pour voir contre qui joue Maxime demain
on va aussi changer la barre
c'est du boulot je vous le dis et on
voit une position
quand même archi complexe une Nimzo avec
F3
F3 donc l'idée c'est évidemment de
prendre le centre à tout de suite
et
chaque criard sur
4 et c'est dangereux
mais voilà ici il sait mettre la
pagaille chaque criard
et on se débute partie c'est une
pagaille assez incroyable depuis un mois
mais la paire de fou et des perspectives
d'attaque sur le roi noir mais si il
vient se cacher de ce côté s'il vient
de mettre ok en C5 qui est en C5 d'abord
et ensuite il voit la zavik plus que
7,50 contre 14 16 attention
chacun va me dire qui est toujours un
joueur hyper intéressant à regarder
très agressif
il faut j'ai trois c'est grand rock la
colonne B est ouverte petit rond qu'on a
le fou quand même qui peut faire
pression mais petit maintenant me semble
moins dangereux pour les noirs
petit rock joué par lasavik il y a plus
que 7 30 alors après il était très bon à
ce truc de Bullet là il a été quand même
très loin la zavik donc ça prouve que
il peut jouer beaucoup de coups beaucoup
de bons coups en une minute donc
attention
c'est pas parce que il va être mal au
temps qu'on va l'enterrer notre ami
laser
mais bon c'est toujours pareil c'est
différent c'est différent évidemment
quand on joue une partie amulette et
quand on joue des parties rapides et
qu'il faut ensuite accélérer le rythme
mais il en est capable
et c'est vrai que d'écureuiles sur H7 on
va pouvoir en faire G6 bon ça fait bien
les cases noires mais on va pas trop
avoir le choix qui est c'est 5 c'est
quand même du solide tout ça
je sais pas trop à quoi ça sert je
m'attends un coup de un coup de tour
centralisateur ça a été joué
deux peut-être un petit coup de G6 pour
demander au fou de choisir sa diagonale
je sais pas ou alors B6 un petit coup de
de soutien aux cavaliers ça peut être
pas mal aussi non c'est pas du 15 + 3
c'est 15 minutes ko contre 10 minutes KO
Armageddon obligation des blancs de
gagner si annule les noix l'emportent et
joue Maxime va chez la grappe demain le
perdant joue Ali Reza
on va tout de suite rappeler le tableau
et l'enjeu de ce match allez rasage
World perdant et Maxime jouera le
gagnant de ce match dès demain
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il
réfléchit 640 oh là là c'est chaque
rayeur qui joue beaucoup plus vite que
son adversaire il veut lui mettre une
pression maximale au temps
on va voir
il est l'habitude de genre de position à
chaque réa il a pas peur tout revu de
coûterait
on sort la tour
et on fait pression plus ou moins sur ce
pion e c'est logique même si on défend
plus F7 mais le temps qui se passe des
choses sur la colonel c'est pas fait H4
voir ça c'est le coup naturel pour pour
chaque créa
il n'hésite pas à envoyer
intéressant
et en plus ça empêche que j'ai 5 surtout
je pense que c'est ça l'idée et sur G6
c'est vrai que ça crée du potentiel H5
et oui alors là il se il essaie de de
faire en sorte qu'il se passe quelque
chose la vie qu'il a pas tort parce que
il peut pas rester dans ce brouillard
dans ses compensations plus ou moins pas
clair il faut quand même un peu de
clarté quand on a aussi peu de temps à
la pendule
et je pense que c'est pas mal quitte à
repeindre le pion mais à simplifier les
choses
c'est une bonne stratégie mais en tout
cas bien malin celui qui peut dire ce
qui va se passer dans ce match parce que
franchement
c'est très ouvert cette position
l'inconvénient de ce coup B5 c'est ça
ouvre la position pour les deux fous et
donc ça peut jouer des tours aussi au
noir
alors comment on va faire
on va faire ici et bien j'en sais rien
c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident a priori on prend déjà
première étape on prend
et ensuite
un coup de dame c'est de pour ma CH7
forcer G6 on affaiblit les cases noires
mais bon
on va voir parce que on va voir comment
il fait chauffer parce qu'il fait ça
bien mieux que tout le monde en partie
Tour Eiffel il espère une embellie sur
F7
c'est ça son truc bon
puis on prend on va reprendre quand même
parce que cahier des trois serait quand
même gênant je pense que chaque criard
va reprendre
mais c'est pas certain
vu sa réflexion
après faut commencer à calculer les
choses comme ça il faut 3 ME la
souffrance F7 ou Fougères
je sais pas
ce qui va se passer ici
ouais ouais ouais
c'est vrai qu'il a l'air
il est m'avait dit
c'est pas quelqu'un de
belliqueux
alors il réfléchit chaque Ryan
comment il va faire
je vois pas quoi y réfléchit honnêtement
mais ça clairement de toute façon je
devine aucun coup je suis un très
mauvais match avec chakrayant je ne
vois pas un coup
je comprends rien à ce qui fait et puis
à la fin ça marche plus ou moins
d'ailleurs moi j'aime mon score contre
j'ai créé un rapide
c'est bizarre ça puisse paraître il me
fait ces trucs que je comprends rien et
je gagne à la fin
bon allez savoir
je joue solide faut jouer solide
clairement
ouais ça attaque le pion au 5 c'était
plus ou moins primovant de la part de
laser qui lui a donné du temps là un peu
gratuitement
on va voir on va voir ce qu'il fait
pas évident pas évident de
pour créer à la de faire du jeu parce
que franchement
le pion est en prise il y a un bon
contrôle du centre il y a un pion de
plus
les menaces blanches sont pas évidentes
mais alors ne l'interromps pas
qu'est-ce qui va jouer
faudrait protéger quand même je crois
que c'est vraiment en prison c'est pas
c'est pas du bluff on a vraiment envie
de le prendre ce pion
fait était dans le top 10 ce qui est
toujours dans le top 10 je pense pas
elle va avoir 2700 chefs Corto M34 je
pense pas qu'il soit dans le top 10 il
doit pas être loin peut-être il y a
encore d'ailleurs
je suis pas sûr
mais gros clients gros client
fou bien ok allez allez on se met sur
les ça y est ça y est c'est parti et on
a regardé
regardez ce qui se passe
on a quand même de l'attaque ici avec
les Blancs c'est pas mal tout ça
il est 16e il est un peu baissé elle est
jeune arrive un goût caché compagnie
c'est quand même c'est du très sérieux
ce qui arrive là en ce moment
F7 et je t'aurais fuites 5,40 contre 850
mais attention je pense qu'en Bullet
pardon s'ils arrivent à une minute
chacun il a aucune chance
son adversaire est beaucoup trop fort
en Bullet donc il doit absolument éviter
ce genre de scénario et se garder un
petit matelas confortable au Hello
pardon excusez-moi vous savez que je
bouge beaucoup je sais que je bouge
Bobby qui dit arrête de bouger tu me
donnes le mal de mer
c'était pas mon intention cher ami
c'est vrai que je bouge ouais je bouge
quand je joue je bouge quand je commente
je bouge quand je commande pas
je bouge tout le temps
c'est comme ça je sais pas pourquoi
c'est la nature mon cher ami mais je
vais essayer de pas bouger
c'est gentil mais oui c'est encore là
c'est encore là c'est que tu aimes bien
ce stream attaque 5 mais attention ça
laisse le pion c'est 6 ouh là là j'aime
pas ça ouh là là j'aime pas ça faut pas
lui laisser deux occas comme ça à chaque
criard attention attaque la tour ça
marche pas ça apparemment qu'est-ce
qu'il y aurait là il y aurait tous ces
cinq
ou il y aurait Cadd 4 je vois rien ça y
est je suis fatigué en fin de stream et
fin de journée mais que va-t-il faire
est-ce qu'il va prendre ou pas on sait
pas
et non et je tourne il protège il donne
pas de coup forcé à la zavie
et
intéressant je lis les en fait j'ai un
truc où je vois tout je vois les
commentaires YouTube et les commentaires
twitch je vois tout d'un seul écran
c'est magnifique
ou la qualité des 8 que la jauge n'aime
pas du tout pourquoi et bien j'en sais
rien
mais ça le mérite de protéger espion
écouter
je sais pas pourquoi c'est mauvais ce
coup mais de rien invitation tactique on
va tricher on va tricher c'est x 2 le
coup de faire très mal et qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur ton 5 et bien tout reprend
tout simplement et sur cavalier prend
tout retroit le clouage le fameux tour
huit fou G3 terminale dos
va-t-il le voir va-t-il faire cavaler de
moi le fois deux je trouve pas ça très
facile x 2
je te remercie je me fais beaucoup aidé
je remercie d'ailleurs tous les gens qui
me supportent et qui m'aident avec
toutes mes questions d'avance stream
parce que je suis en angoissé my
effectivement quand on est pas bon comme
moi pas talentueux pour ce genre de
chose
et qu'on est un peu angoissé et bien ça
donne
ça donne beaucoup de questions les
pendules sont là 7 onze contre 4,30
les pendules sont là
maintenant il prend ses 6 j'aime bien ce
qu'il fait la chakrayer quand même ça
sent bon hein paire de fou 7 minutes
contre 4 30 mais attention il y a un
bonus de rapidité à moi j'ai vu jouer en
Bullet je peux vous dire que
m'étonnerait soit aussi bon
je suis pas bon la technique je merci
mais effectivement j'ai fait beaucoup de
progrès je partais de bas
tous deux ok ok tour 2 est-ce qu'on
aurait pas un petit coup de cahier des
quatre là pour éliminer des deux fous
mais attention il y aurait peut-être fou
prend
pardon pour prendre et aussi soit
j'avais peur de ça là une sorte de
stabilité attention à pas perdre ce pion
ah il m'écoute pas la zavik ah il veut
se venger sur celui-là non parce que
Madame prend des 7 il y aura dams ça
c'est intéressant on va montrer vite
fait il va me prendre des septième et de
me prendre bien il compte sur Salazie et
ouais il a le vif attention si ça
s'accélère s'ils sont au coup d'un coup
au niveau du temps
la dernière seconde je donne pas cher de
la peau de chakraya tour 8 pourquoi je
peux pas prendre et prendre parce qu'il
prend 5 à la fin il compte tenir ça et
là je crois qu'il a raison
même si c'est pas une finale très
plaisante avec les deux fous pour les
blancs ça devrait faire nul
oui je bouge le micro vous voulez me
voir
ouais mais après on entend moins bien
c'est toujours pareil
moi je trouve que c'est bien comme ça on
ne voit pas vous voyez
vous m'entendez en plus c'est pas beau
c'est pas que je bouge faut que je bouge
le micro et puis quoi encore
fois 2 jouer par chaque art qui se fait
rattraper plus ou moins autant x 2 qui
aiment la pression mais bon faut garder
une position aussi jouable c'est ça avec
des chances de gains c'est toujours
pareil c'est pas on peut pas jouer que
la pendule
même si la pendule un élément crucial
évidemment dans ces armées
sinon on jouerait pas ce genre
d'armagidon KBC ok ok
c'est quoi le problème apparemment il y
a pas de problème
comment on va faire ici avec les Noirs
je sais pas ouais c'est ça est-ce que je
pourrais mettre sur un pied en équilibre
s'il te plaît
je tiendrai je tiens pas longtemps en
tout cas ça c'est sûr tour c'est deux et
on essaie de faire venir la tour
participer maintenant menace l'avantage
d'avoir la paire de fou comme l'avait
dit à Nathalie carpov c'est qu'on peut
s'en débarrasser d'un au moment aux
portes et la typiquement
il risque d'y avoir des moments
importants
mais c'est pas sûr
pareil on sait pas est-ce qu'on prend
aussi ou pas j'en sais rien moi
est-ce qu'on améliore la tour par là
peut-être pour ces 6 d'abord intéressant
chaque créat il se pose ce genre de
question mais attention 4,50 contre 3 30
voilà ça jouait derrière la seconde moi
je vous le dis peut-être qu'on doit
acheter pour le pour le perturber c'est
intéressant aussi
alors attention plus qu'une minute de
moins pour la zavik vous voyez hein vous
voyez il a fait le
il a fait il a fait l'accélération
on peut utiliser le fond vert peut-être
dès demain je vais utiliser le fond vert
on va voir un strip-tease genre j'aime
wisigot on va perdre des spectateurs
j'aime visigo là si je fais un
strip-tease je crois
c'est sympathique mais bon
alors
pour ces trois ah protège à trois pour
bouger la dame pour menacer il faut
prendre V6 peut-être vous prend puis on
prend les dames prends menace ça en tout
cas il joue des coups cachés
alors attention
accélère les deux côtés voilà ça a donné
un final
qu'est-ce qui se passe autour des 8
peut-être vous prend aussi c'est tout
reprend F7 pas sûr pas sûr cela dit dans
ton début de fou
simplement attention vous pouvez aussi à
mon avis une menace après on attaque sur
case noire après un coup de H5 un coup
de fou H4 ça peut être très très
dangereux tout ça
attention les avis
attention la zavik dans le dur roche 2
et Dame des 7 pourquoi Dame des 7
pourquoi pas il faut bien jouer un coup
je croyais par cœur il va voir ramener
sa dame quelque part peut-être H5
d'abord ou d'mg4 mais en tout cas il va
lancer une attaque
je sais pas comment il va faire
mais déjà à l'époque il y avait 20 ans
en 2004 il avait un style je me rappelle
le championnat d'Europe on est tous voir
c'est parti parce que tous les jours il
se passait des trucs assez improbables
et H5 est joué ben oui je le connais mon
client le Chakri arma évidemment c'est
un joueur d'attaque il va pas dans un
magasin comme ça il va pas aller contre
la Turquie j'ai 5 est une gaffe
apparemment pourquoi c'est une gaffe je
n'en sais rien on va regarder on va
tricher H6 c'est le bon coup alors si
c'est le bon coup moi j'ai 8 et la tour
F6 le cercueil est apparemment fermé
parce que là on va on va se faire mater
avec ce roi se pur H6 c'est quand même
un gros gros avantage pour les blancs
tout F6 c'est le bon coup ici et toi F6
joué par chaque criard oh là là c'est
terminé apparemment d'après la jauge
mais alors attention menace aussi et mat
derrière un fuite menace énormément de
choses et en fait le roi est assez safe
ici
attention
mais je sais pas si le miracle existe
dans cette position attention il attaque
le Pione 5 il a pas dit son dernier mot
peut-être dame F4 ici la F4 me sens pas
mal attaque et protège c'est souvent une
bonne solution mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire la zavie non
chaque criard chaque créature là c'est
son style de position là dans F4 jouet
cavaliers
je vous prends mes 6 et d'un mec 6 et
fous prends des 5 ah donc on prend
aussi ça va être terminé
on prend aussi dame F6 va être joué
menace vous prend aussi et dame G7 Matt
terminato c'est designable comme on dit
chez nos amis anglo-saxons
et ça va être en abandon de laser
regardez-moi ça oui il est parti
abandon victoire de chaque et à ma média
Rohff qui rejoindra de Nice lazavik
voilà on va à chaque Ryan qui se qui
fait l'interview
on voit la caméra de dos c'est ce qu'on
nous demande normalement on doit voir la
souris d'ailleurs mais bon ok il m'a mis
de l'autre côté c'est pas très grave et
chacun m'avait donné ses avis et donc et
donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire des demain on a un vacher
La Grave ma média en face suivant quatre
parties et on a un fil rouge à laser
simplement
a priori
a priori et évidemment car ça n'est pas
bien chi a priori
si je me raconte pas de bêtises c'est à
18h
ible que les matchs des perdants soit
à 17 heures
mais
[Musique]
je pense que c'est plutôt à 18 donc on
suivra évidemment priorité Maxime achat
graphe qui a gagné son match de manière
assez brillante face à Ali resa firugha
duel fratricide et remporté par Maxime
bravo à lui bravo à manuscrite bravo à
chaque fois bravo à tous les vainqueurs
il y a des pommiers mais personne n'est
éliminé tout le monde peut encore gagner
ce tournoi bravo à vous aussi qui m'a
fait supporter jusqu'à maintenant et si
vous voulez la même punition pour demain
et bien vous connaissez le chemin je
prends l'antenne un peu avant 18h 18h50
et on part pour une deuxième journée
pour ses suivre ces demi-finales je vous
souhaite à tous une excellente soirée
et à demain ciao ciao
match
[Musique]